Oh,
I didn't do that.
That's not me.
I am jumping though.
Look at me go.
I don't know.
Why are you stopping?
Welcome everybody to Atlantis No Nazo.
Oh, get that.
He's just, he's acting on his own, honestly.
I'm surprised he's still alive.
Look at him go.
How does the rage meter work?
Go, jump!
It just happens.
We'll raid it, you know?
Right now it's at 0% rage.
zero percent rage everybody we're good everything is calm
we're we're all good thanks for the gifted patty um if you
are unaware of this game it is just a notoriously difficult
platformer like old from famicom era games it's atlantis no
naso So, um, uh, I don't even know what to say.
Sorry, my brain is so out of sorts today.
Um, one month!
Woohoo!
Thank you guys!
Wait, that'd be one month.
Are these like one months from before I graduated?
Or it's weird saying that.
Or has it been a month since I opened up members?
I can't.
It's been one month since you opened up.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Okay, I'm really confused because memberships are showing
up.
Okay, hold on.
Let me ask, let me check real quick for Streamlabs.
I checked last night but nothing was weird.
But yeah, so I'm gonna do my best with this game.
There's 99 levels.
There's 99...
Wait, what is this?
Interesting.
There's 99 levels.
So I'm going to try and clear everything.
I'm going to do my best.
Excited for Kamige.
Streamlabs test.
Well, I think there was some gifted, so it might be a
little...
Sorry, my brain is really...
Today.
I'm so sorry.
Why did...
What is going on?
I think...
I think Streamlabs changed.
Eh?
Huh?
Okay, that worked, but...
That worked.
Eh?
I'm confused.
Huh?
They changed the whole site.
I don't understand it anymore.
Wait.
Where do I...
Where's my custom ones?
Oh no.
Wait.
Oh.
Eh?
Oh,
tip variation.
Worked!
Yippee!
Okay, it worked.
Okay, sorry guys for that little delay.
Some of these things I can't test, unless I'm on stream,
right?
So...
The CPU in the demo mode is pretty bad.
Now I'm not gonna look... I'm not gonna be as bad as this
guy at all.
So all you can do...
Here I'll show you guys.
Let's start.
Oh my gosh.
First zone mystery adventure start.
Okay, this is just to show you guys how the game works.
So you can throw bombs.
You have to avoid the poop.
And you can duck.
Oh, and you can jump.
And that's it.
When you jump, you can't... Oh my gosh.
You can't move while you're jumping.
It can make things quite difficult.
Wait!
Watch out for the poop.
But, um...
Maybe I could jump over those guys.
Treasure!
And we're here to discover the mystery of Atlantis.
What?
Oh my gosh, I didn't see that guy!
The mystery of Atlantis.
Look at...
I'm gonna keep going.
this way.
Wait, how do I...
Oh my gosh, don't poop on me.
Up?
No.
Hold on.
Maybe bomb it.
Oh, bomb.
Bomb.
Okay, and...
Oh, ah!
You have to throw a bomb at the door.
Oh, I tried.
Let's try this way.
Wait.
No worries, we have seven, five lives.
We have five lives, everybody.
It's all good.
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
Oh, yeah!
Okay, we're good.
Everything's fine.
Don't poop on me.
The little, the poops are like such a full shape, like a
whole poop.
Like it couldn't be like a little pellet.
No, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, hey, hey, hey, maybe it,
maybe it needs to get, like, right on top of it.
No worries,
did I open it?
I don't even know.
Oh, my gosh, oh, my gosh.
Run!
Maybe using the D-Pag would be better.
I don't know why I was Okay It did open Okay, nice, nice,
nice Run
Oh my gosh Oh, bro No, he opened it again Oh, no Oh, no Oh,
I didn't really Oh Oh, boom Boom Boom
Run Run Oh, I thought there was a guy down there.
We're fine.
Don't go through there.
Oh, oh, oh.
Why did you stand back up?
Mr. Adventurer.
Press down and drop a bomb at your feet.
So funny thing, I'll show you.
Oh.
Maybe, hold on.
I'll show you.
Pretty sure You can die to your own bombs Because it's
happened to me I haven't played so much of this I got to
stage like 3 I think So Oh Oh how did I live?
How did I live?
I don't know Yes Wait 11th
Okay You can't crouch and move Okay There's lots of treasure
in here though.
Nice.
Okay, nice, nice.
Wait, how did I jump so high before?
Hey!
Throw!
Oh, no, throw!
Yeah!
Wait, I can't get through there actually.
I only think about it.
Oh.
Uh...
How do you get past here?
Huh?
Open the door for me a little worm!
Oh, there's more worms over here too.
Oh,
wait!
Oh my gosh, when you jump, you can't move- Okay, move
around.
I made it to the 52nd- 52nd, 54th?
Whichever one that was.
Good job, everybody.
Let's try going through that first door.
Actually, I know that leads to the second one.
I was really curious about the other one, which is- Oh, how
did I live?
How did I live?
Yippee!
Where was that door?
I think it really is a pain in the bite that the enemies are
randomized.
I stood up too soon.
No way.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's fine.
Okay, second zone.
Ha!
Wait, those go down.
Oh, treasure, treasure.
Nice.
I don't want to be bought, get, got by my own bomb, though.
Ha!
Okay, nice, nice.
Let's go up.
I don't have no idea where I'm going.
Wait!
That's okay.
Only 600 seconds.
I know, alright?
Oh, oh, oh.
There we go.
At least it's unlimited bomb.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
Nice.
Yeah, get out of here.
Oh, get out of here.
Run.
Nice.
That was close.
Okay, this guy again.
Oh, nice.
Where's the door?
Oh.
Oh, but there's a treasure down there.
Third zone.
If you run, jump, then immediately jump again, you'll jump
higher.
Oh my god.
Are you sure about that?
Oh my god, that was so close.
Oh my god.
You can't move when you jump.
So it's like, you have to, oh my god.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
This dang fish.
Full commit every jump.
It feels like...
Let's try this way.
Oh my god.
Leave me alone!
This guy was targeting me.
It feels like Jump King in that regard.
You know what I mean?
Where it's like Jump King, you have to commit To your...
To your jump.
Jump.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's a good thing I didn't jump.
Jump.
Ah!
Wait.
Six though?
Wait, what?
What just happened?
Wait, how did I get here?
Oh my god.
What is that?
I got something!
Ah!
Eighth, eighty-seven!
Oh my god.
I knew there were warps in this game, but I don't know where
they are, so I'm kind of just like...
Uh... Oh!
We'll find it.
Maybe the pitfall is a secret?
You think so?
Okay, we can't go that way.
This pitfall right here?
I have one life left.
And I don't remember how I got to the sixth zone to get
those shoes.
Should I risk it for the biscuit?
No.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Just throw the bomb.
There's no risk in throwing the bomb.
Only my sanity.
Oh my gosh, sorry, I don't mean to scream.
This game is just a little stressful, is all.
Hey, hey, hey.
Oh, I ended up killing him.
Oh my god.
Ah, the momentum!
No, the momentum!
Get me going.
Oh.
The mystery adventure.
starts.
Okay.
To give you guys any idea, I believe for Korone, it took her
11, almost 12 hours to beat.
And for Game Center, for Arino, it took him 8 hours, I
think, to beat.
which actually um which actually I have as well this is the
same exact one that he used on the show and it shows you it
shows you the different warps and things that you can do so
if we get stuck we're gonna use it okay we're gonna use the
guide if we get stuck okay i'm serious
nice subway map oh my gosh i'm so close i don't know what
the hitbox is on this thing at all wait so this one took me
further maybe i should do this one then 11th zone i'll tell
you in the level where the warp is i am not sure uh it was
this one was it Isn't it?
That we...
50 second!
I can't believe streamer is a cheater.
Oh my god.
It's not cheating!
Why would they provide the map and the guide if they didn't
want you to use it?
Oh my god, wait.
Okay, this is where I learn how to jump at least.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Okay, so far so good.
What is that?
Oh, I got a clock.
But also, I don't think calling me a cheater is very nice,
so please actually don't do that.
Because I think if I, you could call me that if I use save
states, but I'm not, so please don't.
Are there two of you now?
Why won't you shoot bombs when I tell you to?
Oh my gosh.
Go, no.
Go away.
Okay.
Oh.
Wow, I traveled.
No one means it maliciously.
They're just teasing.
telling you I don't want the teasing today not at least at
least not that kind of teasing because I don't think it's
really fair to me thank you oh you
can say skill issue all you want I just think I think I take
offense when it comes to cheating because I am I am I have
too much pride even if I have cheated in my life I don't
like to admit or my afterlife even
this one
she's a loser but not a cheater oh my gosh go away bug okay
Hi.
Hi!
Yes!
Aim!
Urm!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Oh, I did it, I did it, I did it, I did it!
Oh my god, please.
Thank you.
Is there...
Why does this look so suspicious?
Okay, maybe it's nothing.
I don't want to get caught by the bugs.
No, please!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
It's just part of the set design.
Please, please!
Let's go.
Wait, do I have eight lives?
Mommy!
Wait, how do I kill the mummy?
Okay.
One.
Two.
Three.
Can I jump over this?
Oh!
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
I can jump up.
Wait.
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
I can jump up.
No, they're coming from behind!
Whoa!
Oh my god.
No, don't kill me.
Maybe I jump here.
Open.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
57th zone.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wow.
What is going on?
in this.
Okay, just go.
Yo!
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no.
Maybe he can, maybe, maybe.
Can I jump?
Okay.
Oh god, please get me out of here.
I don't want to be in there.
Land is not so anymore.
I hate it.
Okay, we could just stay up top for now.
Probably.
It's probably safe.
Okay, he's gonna fall.
Idiot.
Oh my god, my eyes.
Throw, throw, throw, throw, throw.
Okay, throw, throw, throw, throw, throw.
Okay, we're gaming, we're gaming.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, nice, we got both of them.
We're gaming, we're gaming.
Please get me out of the zone, please.
I thought that would work too.
Oh my god.
Don't take me back to zone...
What is this?
57?
The zone sucks.
The zone sucks so much.
My eyes!
How am I supposed to play like this?
Thank god you have unlimited bombs.
But not unlimited time.
I'm so sorry you guys.
I have no idea.
Come on!
Die already!
Okay, but not me.
Okay, I'm gonna wait for him to drop.
Okay.
Save.
Ah!
Okay.
Oh, that was close.
I always see something on like the right side of my screen.
He's just gonna fall right off.
No!
I don't think it's worth it, you guys.
Staying in this zone!
I don't think it's worth it!
I'd rather just reset!
Okay, I just gotta be good.
I just gotta get good.
Speed run.
Okay.
Just...
Run and jump man!
Oh my god, I can't with these guys.
The slimes.
Oh, oh, yeah!
Oh, yeah!
I'm just gonna die.
I don't wanna do this stage anymore.
We'll come back to it when we have to come back to the 57th
stage.
No!
We'll come back.
Please!
Rip the rave cave.
Why?
Okay.
The mystery begins.
Oh my god.
Why did I?
It's okay.
They said that if a bird poops on you, it's good luck.
I think.
So don't worry about it.
Why is this guy coming up from behind me?
Don't worry about everybody.
Now, also here, I was able to get to the sixth zone.
I can only see green now.
Me too, honestly.
What?
Oh my god.
Wait, let me try going to the left, actually.
Wait, can I make it through there?
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Wait.
Oh, treasure.
I don't know what the treasure is worth.
I don't know if you can only get things through picking them
up, like the items that we found, or if you can get things
in treasure as well.
I'm not sure.
The warp is all the way to the right.
Yeah, but I wanted to see if there was a second door as well
on the left.
It was up here, though, wasn't it?
Okay, there it is.
But the treasure...
Oh, well.
third zone.
I forgot about this area, to be honest!
I forgot about the fish!
Ah!
Oh!
I sent a stream labs warning about the flashing lights, but
it got backed up.
Oh, thank you for trying- oh, heads up, they might have
fixed on the switch, but I remember one stage having
horrible flashing lights.
I see your warning, I'm heeding your warning.
There's like no warning for the fish though.
And it's kind of messing me up.
Ow!
I was so close too.
I'm so frustrated, I was so close.
Okay, that's it.
It's like passing that level.
We'll see if there's a warp past it though, you know, so we
don't have to do it again.
As a certified Kusage enthusiast, I've been waiting for
nearly three years for this.
Well, the time has come, unfortunately.
Oh, I killed him!
Yeah, take that.
Stupid.
The fish!
Yo, the fish.
There's no way to know where they come either!
Oh my god!
I waited for a fish to come!
I waited!
Oh my god.
The fish also waited.
No, I'm not ranging yet.
The fish comes every 225 frames.
So it just happens to be every time I jump, eh?
Look at how happy our guy is.
Go on his little Atlantis adventure.
What could you think the treasure is?
Of Atlantis?
Or not the treasure.
The mystery?
Oh my God.
The mystery of Atlantis.
Also, there was the one where we warp to the sixth stage.
What was it?
It was on the third stage.
What hole?
Oh!
Sorry, I was not looking.
You fell in the pit.
Yeah, but I don't remember which pit it was.
There were a lot of pits.
Not the arm variety, though I wish they were.
Oh, there's a party going on in there.
You would think that throwing a second bomb would like keep
them, keep them down.
you know what i mean but it does not in fact they are immune
oh my gosh the best thing about streaming this game is the
genuine hot tips and wild lies of trolls and one guys are
indistinguishable it's true it's true actually this time
this time we can get the treasure down here let's get the
treasure what could it be there because this game is just it
you could say drop a bomb here and you'll get to level 55
and you could be right.
You could be absolutely correct.
And who am I to...
Oh, there's more.
Who am I to say that you're incorrect?
Oh, nice.
Wait, there's even more!
What is the point of going all the way down here?
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna run out of time though, maybe.
Wait, is it just infinite level?
Huh?
I'm gonna run out of time, though.
Wait, just keep going, keep going.
Oh!
There's another door!
Ninth zone!
Okay, and we got...
What is that?
Hold on.
I got a... something.
Eight!
Eighth zone!
Huh?
Wait, I haven't been here though before, right?
Oh my god, thank goodness I threw that.
The momentum is definitely gonna bite me in the butt.
It's in the zone.
I don't know where I'm at.
Kui!
There we go.
Nice.
Big jump.
It's making me want to pass more of, like, the regular doors
and find the secret.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to go from here.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
the over correction I know because like when you jump you
instinctly want to like you instinctly want to press on like
you know to move forward because you're just like oh my gosh
and then the momentum too okay okay nice hey I think it's
very funny that the guide to this basically encourages you
to like the guide is just like oh by the way there are warps
like you can just totally you can just totally skip a bunch
of this game if you really want to oh hi meant hello hello
if I were a hidden door I'd be right right there all right
I'd be right here Dang.
I tried.
Oh my gosh, please.
There we go.
Where is the door here anyway?
We haven't seen it yet.
Leap!
Jumping in this game is so...
I died to my own boss.
No, biggie.
Oh,
that was close.
That was a close one.
Okay.
I'm getting the hang of the jumping, though, I think.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was close.
That was so close.
Oh, my God.
That was close, too, because I could have died in my own
bomb again.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
We made it!
Okay, this is gonna be like...
Do I even have time to make it through this?
Okay, hold on.
Oh gosh.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I think if I just drop...
Oh, I ran out of time!
I ran out of time!
Yo!
Okay.
Speed run.
Ugh!
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I think I pixel perfect.
Wait!
Okay.
Yo, I'm gaming?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought I touched something on the wall at first.
I was like, what killed me on the wall?
Nice.
Hi.
No, no, not nice.
Nice.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Where's the door?
Did someone sign the door to darkness?
No, not treasure.
Where's the door?
Where's...
Tenth zone!
Let's go!
Oh no, no wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no,
no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no are though I don't think I can get it
we'll come back for you it's
a nice sunny
day can you jump on the clouds no I don't think so I don't
know I didn't try back to zone one everybody
oh good troll are you good
I think jumping on the clouds would be too kind.
The game would be like, oh, I did it again.
I did it again.
I saw the one guy and I just ignored the other guy.
months ghosty thank you you need an item for cloud walking
okay okay okay
i should just jump over these guys but now which way do i
want to go oh why do you have so much poop what are these
birds eating what are these birds eating they have so much
poop
Run!
You're humming along to the beach, yes?
Always the best.
Which way do we go, guys?
They eat too much fat.
They're eating my dead body once a day.
I'm dead.
Once I- my corpse.
That's why they're so- that's why they're able to eat or
poop so much because they're just constantly fading.
Oh!
I'm gonna game over in the first sound!
Okay.
Which way do we go though?
It was stage three that got us to stage six.
So let's try and get to stage three and figure out what the-
how to get to stage six.
We'll drop down.
This one.
Good plan.
Still no go that way.
Treasure.
Please.
Uh, wait.
Yeah, we're going to the second one.
We're going to the first door, I mean.
Because that got us to stage three.
This one right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
First, can I help it?
They're just really nervous around you.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
So I got past a little bit, I think.
Before I fell.
Should I try this one?
Should I try this one, I think?
These fish.
I know.
Okay.
No.
I can't remember where I...
Maybe it was a tiny one like this.
Okay, I'm just going to try it this one.
Happy one month.
Thank you guys so much.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I'm playing this.
I have one month.
One month of membership.
Thank you, everybody.
Oh, oh.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
This is the one I just tried.
It was one of these, wasn't it?
I can't, I don't know which one it was!
Yeah, and thanks for 200k.
Okay.
I swear, I think they wait for you to jump.
I don't think it's every seven seconds.
I think they wait for you to jump and then just intercept
you.
It's so rude!
I think they wait for you to like do an action.
Oh.
Well, it's not that one.
I don't know which one.
I don't know.
This game is 100% designed to be rude.
I agree.
I don't think I got- I don't think it was this far that I
made it.
Oh my gosh.
Fish.
Six, seven!
You know what, let's just keep going then.
One, two, three, four, five.
Oh, oh yeah.
Sorry.
Press the wrong button.
Was it worth it?
Okay, we're gonna find it now.
this one it was not that one this one no maybe it was um
maybe it was the one after that maybe this one
wait This one?
Ah!
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Six zone!
Oh my god, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh.
I got an item!
I got the shoe- I got shoes!
Oh no, wait, this one was really hard.
No.
Ah!
You know what, it's fine because we wasted some lives on
level 3, so it's whatever.
Don't worry about it.
We wasted some lives on level 3, so...
Okay, we gotta get to level 3 without dying.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Oh.
Thanks, Varylant.
Takeshi's challenge?
I think it's on par.
Second zone.
This jeopardizes your goal.
It's okay.
This one's easy.
There's no pitfalls.
Just gotta avoid these guys.
Why am I so weak?
I can't even handle a hermit crab.
Oh my god, how did I live that?
How did I live that?
What is this?
Atlantis is so mysterious.
Truly.
The most mysterious place.
Okay.
Third zone.
Have you seen the size of those hermit crabs?
Still, they're really cool too, like they're wearing their
sunglasses.
Okay, now I have to find this one.
You rage!
Personally like this Mint Center CX arrow we've got.
I don't mind.
Like, I think some people are just like, I hate playing rage
games because you know they're designed to make you rage but
I personally am like a fan of being like of hopefully
beating them oh my god no okay we have three lives
like I think it's like the best feeling in the world to
clear something that is Is meant to be so frustrating.
Okay, it was one.
I see the fish.
I see the fish and my finger still says, Hey!
You know what, I think I'm just gonna die.
Actually, no.
I'm not.
I will continue on.
I will continue onward.
When the going gets tough, you'll pull through like you
always do.
Thank you.
Okay.
It was.
This one.
Yes.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Nice.
Okay, eighth zone.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright.
I wonder what the boots don't make me faster or anything.
I don't think.
I hope not.
Please, God, don't give me more speed in this game.
I will cry.
If I have to go any further or faster than I have, please
actually just give me like, just stop the momentum.
That would be the better gift, truly.
When they like start coming back to live, these little
hermit crabs, it's like two seconds that they give you of a
warning.
It's crazy.
Momentum.
I felt so close.
Okay.
That was so close.
Momentum.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
I think I can just drop there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Sorry.
Oh my god, I'm so stressed.
Okay, treasure chest.
Nice.
The time limit!
Oh!
It's so brutal!
You would think that 900 seconds is a lot.
Even Mario gives you, like, a thousand doesn't don't they
sometimes i gotta take my time not in no there's no time in
atlantis
oh oh oh my god oh oh my gosh that was so close let's wait
for this guy to go down yep there we go okay here okay okay
oh okay
Oh Pain
You know what I'll say 1% We're at 1% Wow, what's this
level?
It's funny because I can't I can like kind of control this
guy like I can jump, but I I can't throw anything and also I
didn't make that jump either I don't know.
I don't understand.
Wait.
Oh, I ended up dying Okay, let's go.
There's no better way than I'd want to spend my Saturday.
No better way than I want to spend my Saturday traveling.
Okay, I said 900 seconds.
These are way faster than seconds.
Ah!
No better way than spend my Saturday.
Just 2% now.
I'm dying on purpose by the way so that we can just I wonder
if there's a way for me to just reset.
I don't think so.
Just let me die already.
No better way.
Spend my Saturday.
Bada-dada-dada-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-
When I'm trying to die, the deaths feel so...
Oh wait, I instinctively just jumped over him.
You could be watching an idol live, and yet here you are.
Where would I be watching an idol live?
I'm not in Japan.
Hello.
No, no, no, no.
Poop, poop.
Stage two.
You could be watching Idol Live VOD on YouTube.
So true.
Actually, it's like so frustrating sometimes being for an
Idol fan because like, they film shows.
I know they do.
I see the cameras in the back.
But they don't post them.
Like, 99% of the time.
They never post the show itself.
So if I miss a show, like, that's kind of it.
And sometimes they'll perform, like, a special set list.
It's mostly frustrating for birthdays because they'll
perform, like, a special set list.
And I'm like, no, please.
Please.
I just, oh, I want to see you perform this song.
I think it is for them to, like, watch back and practice
and, like, you know.
like where maybe they made mistakes or certain parts but
like it's still so it's just so sad okay i'm waiting for
fish okay it was the third one here
fish Fish?
Oh!
Okay.
This one.
Six zones!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
He came out of nowhere.
Okay.
Gotta go fast.
Okay, this is not very fast.
Pew.
Faster!
Nazo Man!
Please, faster, faster!
Just ride like your little legs versus ride.
Just ride.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
This part is tricky, but we got this.
Oh, gosh.
I don't have this.
Okay.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Please.
You know what?
Screw it.
I don't have...
AHHHHH!
We're fine.
Oh my god.
Where did you come from?
I even threw the bomb and it didn't even affect him.
Just run.
Run and jump.
Oh my god.
Okay.
No!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I think actually that did stop him.
I don't know why this stage gives me so much trouble.
It's so much hopping.
Oh no,
and he's right there.
Okay.
The momentum.
Don't forget the basics of CQC mods or something.
Yeah, thanks.
Oh, the momentum.
That wasn't even me overcorrecting at that time.
Okay, just in case.
Sometimes I die.
Sometimes I don't.
The game doesn't even know.
I don't know what my own hitbox is.
I have no idea.
I have no idea!
Tough time never lasts.
Only tough people last.
You guys, I don't think we're making it to level 9, so...
You aren't playing through OBS, are you?
No, I'm actually not.
I thought...
I'm actually not playing through OBS.
It's only been an hour.
Maybe try with OBS.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm too used to OBS now.
Where did the other one, the other door in here, take me?
I can't remember.
Oh, okay.
Just run.
Just run and jump.
There we go.
Oh, guys, there's so many tiny little...
Oh, I thought I was gonna die there.
I thought for sure I would die there.
Okay, third zone.
No fish, no fish, no fish, no fish, no fish, no fish.
No fish, sorry, I'm allergic.
To fish.
Okay.
Fish.
Here.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot.
Why is everything pooping on me?
Okay.
Ah, please!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
I
thought I was gonna land on top of that other one, so...
Okay.
The music in this, I think, stresses me out.
It's so fast-paced, you know?
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna die.
Oh, I thought I was gonna die!
Big leaps.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, all right.
Very good.
Okay, nothing here.
Nothing here.
Okay.
I have to wait.
I jumped but I didn't.
Maybe do it soon enough.
Come on, come on, come on.
There's no time to lose.
Oh my god.
Why wasn't he affected by the bomb?
Sometimes it really doesn't read my inputs, but that's okay.
Like there, I tried jumping just then.
Might be my controller.
No, no, it's just a skill issue.
Real gamers don't blame the controller.
I'm a gamer.
Yeah, we do.
Actually, maybe that's the most gamer thing to do is to
blame the controller.
Why?
There we go.
Okay.
Please, please.
Thank you.
Okay.
We made it to the treasure chest.
Okay, just don't even try.
Just go.
Please.
Just make it to the door.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Tenth zone!
Oh, tenth zone!
Okay, clouds.
Oh my gosh.
No, I missed the star!
Uh-oh.
It's Jover.
It's Jover, you guys.
I missed the...
I missed it.
Maybe there will be another one.
Oh!
That was me.
Oh wait, we got another chance.
We got another chance.
Hi.
I was too...
I got it!
I got
it!
Oh my god.
Oh my
god.
Wait!
That was from here, right?
Yes.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, okay, okay.
This is the most stressful level.
Oh my god, this is the most stressful level.
I remember playing in my entire afterlife.
Oh my god, oh my god, you guys.
I can barely breathe.
breathe.
Oh my gosh, I can barely breathe.
You're stressing me out.
It's, what am I doing?
It's the game.
Oh my god.
Beep, beep, beep.
Don't.
No.
Okay.
I think this level wouldn't be as bad if I didn't have to go
through level 8 before.
Oh no!
If I didn't have to go through level 8 before, I would...
Oh!
Poop.
Called it, man.
You guys.
That's why I don't have a death counter.
No, my.
When someone way better at games than me.
Takes three hours on one stage.
I think.
I think we.
You know what?
I'm going to go up.
I think we can.
Right.
recognize the trouble we are in.
But I have to get it eventually.
I have to get it eventually.
It has to come eventually.
Death count.
Pretty much.
Okay, fish.
Oh, that was close.
Okay.
Six zone.
Level 8.
The pain of my existence, level 8.
Because it's so long!
It's also like so...
Oh my god.
It's also so long.
It takes so long to get through it.
Maybe it's just me.
Maybe, you know what, looking at it, it's actually not that
long.
I think it's just me.
Okay.
I ran and jumped!
I ran and I jumped and I still only did a tiny jump.
That could have been close.
Come on.
That didn't even do anything there.
I just, I just, I just jumped and the guy ran, decided to
run on his own.
I threw my bomb too late.
Oh, yo, yo.
Look on the bright side.
You could be playing a harder NES game.
This game is easy.
Look on the bright side.
This game, a baby could do it.
Thank you.
You know what?
Always look on the bright side.
Oh, I don't know why sometimes I die to the bombs and
sometimes I don't.
I think if I jump, I don't die to the bomb.
Thanks for the super chat!
I'll read it.
Is there a reason for...
Oh, wait.
Insane timer?
I have no idea.
Because this game, I think, was designed to literally hate
you.
It's designed to make you so sad.
It's designed to make you really, really sad.
Please, please.
Okay.
There we go.
It's designed to make you cry.
We're so close.
Okay, we have only three lives left.
Thank you, Kyoki!
I feel like I'm at least getting better at the previous
level though, so...
Okay.
Got the star.
Oh my god, no!
Jump is so tricky.
One life left, everybody.
What if I go backwards?
What if I go this way?
Never mind!
Jump!
And jump!
Poop!
Door.
You earned that game over.
Yeah, I did.
What was she cooking?
Look, I have one life left.
What am I gonna do?
Experiment when I have 50 lives?
What?
This game needs to give you 50 lives, speaking of.
The life...
They need to give you more lives in this game.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh my god, I didn't think I would make that.
I didn't think I would make that at all.
Look it!
There are cheats that let you add lives?
No way, really!
This one I can take a little bit slower because...
Oh my gosh.
Because it's right, like, here that way.
Fish.
It's right here.
You're just holding back on how good you are to make us feel
better.
I...
I encourage you, play this game.
Play it.
I encourage you.
I'm not looking to beat any records.
Oh my god.
No!
That was so dirty.
Oh my gosh.
But no, actually play it.
Try it.
I'm not trying to beat any records here.
But just to give you an idea, Korone San took about 12
hours.
And in Game Center CX, between two people, Adino took about
eight and a half, eight hours?
Eight and a half hours?
So, what is the speed run on this game?
What is the speed run?
on this game.
I don't even want to know actually.
I think I'll throw up.
Ah!
Wait.
Uh-oh.
I'm losing a lot of time.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
I have to be quicker with these.
No.
Oh gosh.
I gotta be fast.
No!
Three minutes!
Oh, for Tass Run though?
Come on.
That doesn't count.
Tass Run doesn't count.
I mean, for real people.
I'll look in a second.
I'm concentrating.
Concentrating.
Holy cow.
How do I make that?
Just mint.
Just mint gaming.
Oh my gosh, please.
I need to make this.
Why?
Please, sir.
There we go.
Okay.
Here's the tough one.
I think, I don't think 225 is Taz.
Really?
No way.
No way!
I need this guy to stop falling from the ceiling.
He's scaring me.
He's stressing me out a little bit.
No, why are you gonna be down there?
Wait.
Okay, okay.
Okay, here, here's where I really mess up.
So, okay, there we go.
Nice, nice, nice soup.
I think I have time.
But I'm not gonna risk it.
Just go, don't risk it for the biscuit.
It's not worth it, it's not even delicious, it's dry.
Don't risk it for the biscuit.
Okay.
Oh, hold on.
Hold on.
Mods, doko.
They're probably just like, we can't watch this anymore.
This is...
This is too stressful.
This is too stressful on my little heart.
Oh.
Oh, how did I make that?
Oh my gosh, please, please, please.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, the timer is just going.
It's just going.
Oh, that was a pretty good run, though.
That was a pretty good run.
All things.
All things considered.
You.
You!
Oh, well, I didn't make it anyway.
Oh, gosh.
You're getting better.
I don't think there's a way to get better at this game, I'll
be honest.
I think this game is just so, so evil.
This game is not meant to, you're not supposed to get better
at this game.
I don't think, I think...
No!
I don't know how much skill comes into this.
That's what I'm saying.
I have to, like, at least with this one, I feel like I have
to memorize.
Why?
I have to memorize how...
Where I stand, the standing placement, and how much I press
down on the button, and everything.
I have to memorize so much.
Oh, oh, I...
Sorry, I totally it.
Oh, the game was made by a sadist.
I'm going to start up my...
I'm going to...
I got a coffee.
It might not actually be good for me to have this because
it'll make my hands shaky, but...
I'm okay.
Yeah.
Hmm.
No.
Mmm.
Rage back down to zero.
Yummy, yummy.
Just count your lucky stars.
This isn't super pitfall.
You'd be mentally barfing.
Wait, you wanna take that back?
You wanna take that back?
Actually...
Hold on.
I'm gonna die.
Because I do want to see how far I can... Okay, hold on.
I want to get to the level 54 again.
I want to go that route.
Because I'm pretty sure there's another warp there.
Because from what I remember, there's a way to get all the
way to level 99.
What?
So...
Sorry.
Maybe I should have done this before I...
No, no, we're not gonna go through the rave room.
I think you can skip it.
I'm gonna check the guide real quick once we're done.
Yeah, there's a hidden door.
Okay, okay, I thought so, I thought so.
I thought so, I thought so.
So we're gonna...
We're gonna die.
And we're gonna...
Because I do wanna see...
I mean, if I can just beat the game by getting a level 99,
then...
Okay.
Was that my last one?
Yeah, okay strategy guide.
Okay, let me see now Okay, oh here so
11 this is wait is that where we know 11 52.
Yes, yes, yes for 91.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, so a 1 to 11
Okay It doesn't say how I get to level 91.
Hmm.
What the hell is this map?
This is the levels for this game.
See, you can go 1, 2, 3, 4.
Wait, you can't even go from 4 to 5?
What is that?
Wait.
5 there there is huh oh it's oh I see it's below 2 okay 5
can also get you to 24 but how do you get 4 to 5 what the
heck is that thing 5 to 6 6 and then 6 to 7 You can go...
Wait.
But we're going to go to 11.
And then we're going to go to 52.
I can't read that.
Gimetsuwap.
And then he can go to zone 91.
But what's the warp?
The 91 to 95.
To 93.
96.
Yeah, we can get...
the final oh oops we can get there maybe 11 is the highway
what about 20 to 100.
yeah how do we okay 9 8 20.
right wait okay hold on oh
so nine to eight to twenty wait nine to eight to twenty to a
hundred that's a plausible possible path yeah let's try it
out oh yeah sorry i keep clicking on the wrong thing okay
there we go okay it was from two right two nine eight twenty
Oh, two, two, two.
Wait, okay, two to a...
That's probably the one where we run past this door here.
So let's just stay down.
Stay down.
We'll stay down.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was close.
I was so close.
Run past you.
Okay, run past you.
I don't remember where the door is.
Oh, that's so unfair.
They're on top of the treasure box.
I don't have much time, though, so I gotta zip.
I gotta zip itty.
Okay, never mind.
Door.
Did someone say...
save the door to darkness?
Okay, ninth zone.
Wait, was this right?
Was this correct?
I think this gives me an extra life.
From nine to eight.
Oh, that's right, yes.
And then we went back to eight.
Yes, yes, yes.
And then eight to twenty.
Wait.
Oh, no.
There's Oh, oh god.
For some reason, my brain did not comprehend that.
Okay.
Let's look for any places like that a door, like, I feel
like in here, you know, like, and a little dip at the
bottom, like a door.
Oh, wait.
Unless I run past.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I already messed up then at that point.
messed up but that's okay because I've wasted a lot of time
I don't know if it's a hidden door or if it's a door past
the initial door but that's okay this song in particular
will haunt me you wouldn't think a ghost could get haunted
but...
Okay, nice.
I touched him.
What if I'm, like, really deathly allergic to shellfish or
something?
And so that's why it's, like, really dangerous for me.
To touch these guys, you know?
I'm just so...
deathly allergic to shellfish.
Oh my gosh.
I almost overcorrected that.
That would have been bad.
Nice.
Alright.
That was...
Now we...
Okay.
Jeez, you can hit yourself.
Yeah, you can.
But only...
I think it's only if you hit yourself in the face.
Thank you for the pink.
Thank you.
I mean, you could blame me.
for like throwing it preemptively but also can you blame me
for throwing it preemptively because like
sometimes i'm like am i gonna make this like see
like that
okay nice
we wait for him to drop down then we jump across like so
Okay.
Now we're running past this door.
Hopefully, it's shortly past.
I got
something.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh my god!
Please, please!
20th zone!
20th zone?
It's the own 20, it's the own 20.
Keyword!
Nagoya!
What just happened?
Why am I back here?
Why am I...
Why am I back?
Why am I back here?
Was I not supposed...
Was I supposed to ignore that door?
Keyword!
And the...
I didn't know this was a Metal Gear game.
I threw my bomb too late.
Wait, wait.
I think you have to go backwards on 20th.
If we make it, if we make it there again, we'll try.
Though, I'll be honest.
Even if I get to level 100, um through this method i think
i'll keep i i don't know it feels too easy right like i've
only been playing for two hours less than two hours so i do
want to try maybe the other method the 11 to 50 to oh oops i
forgot where i was at to to i don't know is there anyone who
has played this game levels Levels one.
Oh my gosh.
Ugh.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Shoo-shaw.
Levels like in complete order, I wonder.
Oof.
Okay, nice.
Shoo.
Oh, wait.
Can I go back?
Can I like...
No.
Oh my god!
No way.
No!
No way!
And it reset the counter!
Yo!
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me right now?
That's incredible.
Best game ever.
Do I bomb them?
Keyword Nagoya.
Oh.
Wait, I can jump on these guys.
No, no, no, no.
Oh.
Uh.
Nagoya.
Keyword Nagoya.
I'm afraid to jump.
It sounds like a classical song that like someone made when
they were when they had like scarlet fever or something like
I have the black plague my mind is going.
Why didn't it stop him?
The bomb.
Maybe you have to jump on their heads in a certain order.
No idea.
It might be time to give up on this route.
If there was, like, no way.
How do you do it, though?
Do I have to blow them up, maybe, like, in a special way?
I'm just not sure.
So this must be endless aid everyone here's talking about.
Let's see.
Hello.
Oh, please.
Uh-oh, we've wasted a lot of time.
A lot of time.
I don't even know if I'll make it to level 10.
Oh, how did I do that?
Oh, shoot.
But if I do, I can just go back.
If you're still at this at six hours, we'll tell you how the
Naglia room works.
You're too kind.
Kato Arino also has mint clothes.
Oh, look at that.
It's closed now.
Isn't that kind of funny?
But also, you're right.
Arino does have...
It does have mint clothes.
The Nagoya room is actually unsolvable.
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
And also, like, if I practice here...
Yeah, so you like...
But it's in the guide that you can go from...
From 20 to...
It's solvable?
Do I have to, like, get it in their mind?
mouths.
It's a secret code.
Na...
Go...
Yeah.
Something to do with the plants.
I think this is my last life anyway, so it's probably fine
to...
You were in Nagoya.
Yeah.
Oh!
I wasn't my last one.
Nah!
Seven.
So seven there.
Go!
One, two, three, four, five.
Yeah!
Eight?
I don't know.
Actually, uh...
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Do I have to like get it on top of their heads?
Like if I...
Do I have to like blow up like seven on top of their heads?
See,
see, see, see?
Oh my god, that's like so hard.
That's actually so hard.
Ah, so tricky!
Ah, so close!
Ah, I think I...
Oh, dang.
It's like pixel perfect.
Drop it by crouching?
What if I...
Oh, no.
It doesn't need one, two...
How do I even know if it's working?
Three, four, five, six, seven.
Either of you go on top and drop them.
It still doesn't work.
Wait, maybe like this.
Come on.
Okay, I think I give up on this method.
I think I give up on this method.
All right, let's go back to the drawing board, everybody.
Let's go back to the drawing board.
Where did I put my window?
Uh-oh.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, I lost it.
There it is.
Okay.
Um.
I think we gotta try the 1 to 11.
52.
Okay, when we get to 52, where is the door?
Hmm.
Wow, Atlantis is truly a...
It's truly...
Oh my god.
Truly a mysterious place.
That was so close.
Very naso indeed.
Oh, I'm just gonna jump over you guys.
Yeah, I'm still not raging.
I think I'm still okay.
Nice.
Has it honestly been a month already?
That's crazy.
Here I am.
Not raging.
Oh my god.
Okay, 11th zone.
I don't remember what this zone was like.
Oh, yes, I do remember.
I have to blow myself up here.
Let's get some treasure, though.
Very nice.
I have to blow myself up here.
Then we go to the 52nd zone.
52nd.
Oh, I do remember this zone.
Locusts.
Please, please, leave me alone!
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Please!
Okay, just keep going.
Please throw a bomb!
Okay, okay.
Nice.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is where the...
This is where we're supposed to find the other door.
The other door to darkness.
Oh gosh.
Um...
Oh...
Is it on one of these platforms?
Oh, shoot.
Um...
Because if we go down here...
Oh, shoot.
Yes.
Okay, good.
Maybe like, uh...
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot!
No, no, no, I can't go through that one!
Oh my god, please.
Is it past the other door?
I don't think so.
I don't think I can run- I don't think I can jump over that.
Unless...
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
I can't go back.
I'm stuck here.
Shoot.
Oh.
Okay.
And we're stuck here too.
Now we're stuck here.
Okay.
That's fine.
It doesn't take much to get to the next level, so...
Or to get to from 11 to 50, whatever?
50, 54?
So I think we'll be okay.
How does Mint know all of that?
All of what?
What do I know?
I don't know anything.
52.
Thank you.
Nine.
I always love retro gameplay.
yeah i do too until it's like this you know orly that should
have been mine that should oh wait i think i messed up you
guys uh-oh
go go go go okay game over
if i were a hidden door Where would I be?
If I were a hidden door.
Where?
Where would I be?
Oh, that was so close.
Gosher!
Thank you so much for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Also, wait, I'm so sorry.
Someone also super chatted the pink earlier.
while listening to your screens and I woke up to a bee in my
hair!
I like bees but that freaked me out.
How's this, how's this going?
Are you winning?
Schwanky.
I'm so sorry you had a bee in your hair.
What?
That sounds a little frightening.
She's winning.
Maybe like right here.
Not there.
Maybe where this treasure box is.
Shoot.
Never mind.
Do you think I...
Yeah.
Okay, not where the treasure box is.
Oh my god.
There we go.
What?
I got that!
Excuse me!
I got that so...
No.
No!
This game cheated me.
Okay.
Here?
Oh, I think I tried here before.
Also, if you're trying to say what it is in the chat, please
don't, because I am not asking for answers right now.
You know what?
Let's just try anywhere.
I didn't want enough.
We lost the 50-50.
What's the- what were you betting on?
What are you betting on, huh?
It wasn't here.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god!
Oh,
I jumped too much now.
Maybe next to the treasure chest.
You're doing amazing?
Thank you.
Please.
Why can't it be consistent with the enemies, you know?
All I'm asking for is...
Oh my god.
All I'm asking for is a little consistency here.
Just think about Nagoya.
Nagoya is the key word to beating this game.
Oh!
Oh my god, I took out two bugs with one bomb!
You know what they say?
Two bugs with one bomb.
Wait, I lost the timer again.
Yeah.
Take my wrath.
Take my...
Fury!
I got bugged.
No,
please.
Please stop coming for me.
I can't.
Is that a game over?
Now I
won't feel so bad.
Oh, I dropped a bomb instead of jumping, my bad.
Now I won't feel so bad if we get all the way to...
to, um...
the final levels because it's already been a challenge
enough getting...
getting there.
And we're gonna...
You're totally bugged.
No.
This game is genuinely about the journey.
It's about something.
We're just a little guy trying to find Atlantis.
Actually, are we in Atlantis?
Or are we going to Atlantis?
I'm kind of confused about that part.
Because like if we found Atlantis and we're here In Atlantis
But like What's the mystery Why it's built like this?
No wonder everybody died in Atlantis Look how your society
is built Look how your society is built Okay here we go
We're back baby Bug He's just so so slowly grazes my head.
It's so funny.
It's not funny at all.
It's so frustrating.
Okay, there we go.
And then if I hadn't made that jump, that would have been so
sad.
I can't throw another bomb until the one explodes, which
also just really messes me up.
It really grinds my gears.
Yes.
Okay.
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Okay, here, here, maybe.
Wow!
Yes!
That was what I was hoping for.
Throw!
Is it next to the other door?
They wouldn't do that, would they?
Uh-oh.
There we go.
It's not next to the other door, is it?
I have to, like, throw it, so...
Oh.
Okay, it's not.
Maybe if I throw it from here, maybe that's the key.
No.
Okay.
They're not trying to give me hints at all.
Bug!
But sometimes it's also pretty specific.
What did I throw it from here?
Oh, there, there, there, there.
Oh, no.
Aha!
Time out!
It's okay.
We're gonna have to do a lot of trial and error for this.
So, honestly, it's best that we time out than getting
bugged.
At least I...
Look at him.
What an idiot.
Now he's gonna drown!
Oh, you don't drown, but I can.
Okay, this is fine.
This is fine.
Okay, where...
Oh.
Could it be?
Oh wait, oh my god.
Maybe like I stand here and throw it.
You know?
Maybe the opening is like a little...
Oh shoot.
He's built it for 50 seconds.
Okay, it's not there.
No, is it, did I try next to the treasure box?
I don't think I, there we go, nice.
I don't think I have, maybe if I aim from here.
Aim.
Okay, I give up.
I don't know.
Can you get exploded by your own bombs?
You can.
You actually can.
Okay, actually, what if I do this instead?
No.
Why do you throw it so much, you dummy?
I'm gonna run out of time again.
Okay, I want a hint.
Do you want a hint?
Yeah, just a hint.
Don't tell me where.
But just a hint.
Like, check.
Check.
Where the pillar meets three.
One mondiata!
Thank you.
Hint of the last platform.
Like...
Where the like right before the door or where the door is
The last platform
So this platform It's under there under where only one hint
last platform.
Okay, okay, okay, okay So wait if I I wanted to jump and
then throw it on back onto the other platform.
Oh man.
Mommy?
Sorry.
While we run out of lives, I'm gonna go to the bathroom real
quick.
I'm gonna go to the little ghosty's room.
I hope you do not mind I will be right back let me make okay
I'll be right back while I go to the ghosties room you guys
get some water as well
I'm back I'm still alive how am I still alive Yippee!
No!
Game over!
Perfect timing, right?
Okay, I'm gonna look back at the guide one more time.
Is there something we missed about what it says for the
route?
Can I zoom in a little bit more?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Saitan route.
That's Saitan.
Saitan.
Muteki route.
High score route.
Wow.
What kind of masochist do you have to be to go for a high
score in this game?
Zen item route.
Oh no way.
No thank you.
scoreblades.
If I'm not top 50, why even play?
I'm afraid of anyone that is that holds a record in this
game.
I'm terrified of anybody that holds a record in this game.
Hold on.
I'm bank your time.
Oh, okay.
Saitan is just the shortest.
Okay, that's why I figured, but...
Hmm.
But
then...
What's the red route?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
One, two, three, eight, ten.
Four.
Have we done four before?
What is this?
The star?
Okay, you get a bunch of items.
Oh, oh no!
What page were we on?
Uh...
Uh-oh, I lost my page.
Oh, there we go.
Um, 25.
So it's the shortest, but it says it's an invincible route.
But 10!
We have to go through 10!
Okay, it says from 97 to 100.
The shoes are...
You have to have the shoes.
Okay.
interesting so from 97 to 100 you have to have the shoes for
this route but this one bypasses the one that we're doing
the the this one bypasses actually how many how many stages
are in this red route versus the orange route let's see can
we get a coffee meter i've only have one can i only everyone
can so the shoes you say the shoes here like you get six so
this is one two three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve okay one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten did i count 100 on the first one i don't remember
12 in the red route so it's not even that big Okay, so we
have our two routes, I think we should- we would have to go,
why?
But I'm- this one is called the invincibility route.
So what does that even mean?
I have to beat level 10 though!
Oh god.
And then this thing that I need the shoes worries me.
What's going on in 97 that I need the shoes?
huh?
Try Nagoya route again.
What does it say for that one?
Ah, sorry.
It's the blue route.
That's the high score route.
How does that even make any sense if you go from 8 to 20 to
100?
I guess you get the 400 points.
Oh, no.
400.
Oh, my God.
400 400 Oh my god You get a lot of points actually You get a
ton of bajillion points Hmm Real question is how long is the
longest route you can take I guess in regular order right
I think Okay I'll try and get the uh the we'll try for 52
again I wonder what this little thing is uh we'll try for 52
again and then um
I'll try and find it I'll try and find it okay okay Okay,
all right.
Ike-mashou.
Where's my...
Okay.
Dark blue line looks really long.
Wow.
Let's go try and find us a hidden passage.
Beep.
You guys said the hit was the last platform.
We can give another hit when you're ready.
No, it's okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
Explosion!
Do you eventually loop around?
to loving this song love is a strong word I think just as
hate hate and love are two sides of the same coin right
right I know
I get pretty close to them but It's the only way I can
assure true and total death.
True and total death.
Okay.
If I just drop here.
All right.
No.
Oh no no no no no no.
That's okay.
We still have seven lives left.
Are you winning, Minto?
We're making problems.
progress somehow we are making progress there's there's some
progress being made i mean we're level 54 you guys oh we're
level we're in the 50s oh my gosh oh oh that was so close
that's what you get for getting too close to me
50 seconds How did you find out about this game originally?
I originally watched the Game Center CX But also I watched
Korone play it And so I was Oh wrong button Oh my gosh so
dangerous Here So that's what got me interested in playing
it.
Oh.
What is Game Center CX?
Oh my gosh, it's so awesome.
Game Center CX is like a show where this guy just tries a
bunch of games and like he has like some rage challenges as
well.
Like he played Takashi's castle and everything and oh my
god, I'm going to die!
The bug!
Japanese Oji-san Gamer Show.
It's really funny.
We love Arino Kachon.
Oh.
Why do I have a flu?
I went flying.
Okay.
I like when there's only one bug there.
Makes things a little bit easier.
I'm afraid of the other route just because of...
Oh my gosh, I thought I was gonna die there, because I'd
have to go through level eight and 10.
But if that's what we gotta do, a baby's gotta do what a
baby's gotta do.
I can't even get to the end of the last platform anymore,
man.
Oh, that was so close.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
No, no.
Okay, last platform.
I'm just gonna blow up everywhere that I can.
Oh, uh oh.
Oh, I got one guy at least.
Please.
There we go.
Last platform.
Oh, this is this.
Oh.
Maybe the hole in the fence is a hint.
I've tried it, though.
I tried it.
I'm going to run out of time with this ray.
Like, I thought maybe shooting in there.
Oh, nice.
But it doesn't do anything.
No.
Maybe if I shoot from here, no.
Jump and shoot.
Go away, bug.
You're bugging me.
Oh, I believe it.
It's okay.
I was out of time anyway.
I don't know.
Yeah, I've blown up every spot of that part.
Oh my gosh.
Go away.
Let's see.
Hmm.
No.
Oh my god.
I overjumped.
I really want to find that spot though!
Is this another drop down entrance?
I don't think so.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Whoop!
Poop!
Whoa!
Why are you higher than the last guy?
Poop.
Ba-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Blow.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Okay, we're back, baby.
Why did I...
No worries.
I think we got an extra life somehow, so it's like we didn't
even die.
There we go.
Oh no!
Oh my god, now it's two of them!
Oh shoot.
Okay, at least got one of them.
Oh!
Uh oh.
Die.
Please die.
That was really close.
I almost overcompensated too much on that too.
Hey!
And we're back, baby, with our regularly scheduled
programming.
Last platform.
Unless it means...
No!
It's not there for sure.
Theory crafting time.
Atlantis sucks.
You know what?
No wonder everybody died here.
Unless it's...
Is it like a...
No, it wouldn't be like, I can't, I can't be above the door
because...
Oh my god.
That's a great theory.
Okay, can I get a hit number two?
Can I get a hit number two?
Have you tried under the bridge?
Is it actually an under door?
bad.
It's not an invisible door.
What?
What do you mean by that?
Under the bridge.
Oh my god.
The last platform.
I don't know if I've fallen here before.
Have I fallen here?
Okay, it wasn't that.
Oh, oh, oh!
Okay, come here, bugs.
I need to know how many there are of you.
Nice!
Sometimes the RNG just works.
Sometimes the RNG just...
helps out a little bit.
Maybe at this platform?
Here?
Wee!
I remember watching a dog play this.
Yeah!
It's already a month.
Here's so many more.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
You're getting closer.
Oh,
I wasn't sure I was going to make that.
Maybe it is just safer to duck from those guys.
Because they're inconsistent as well as like how far apart
they are sometimes.
Anka!
They say we're not a duck.
We're vultures!
Poop, poop, and throw.
I don't think they're ducks.
I don't think they are either.
I do not think they're ducks at all.
52nd zone.
Please.
I want to see the 54th.
I think it was 54 after this?
Oh, I meant to jump before I do that.
Beep, beep, beep.
Is it in between?
No.
Oh, boy.
Oh, oh, oh.
All that just to die anyway.
Same method as the last level.
So I blow myself up?
Are you sure?
Maybe I blow myself up in the, um...
Hold on, like in this area.
Here?
Blow up!
Oh!
Blow up.
No,
no, no, not to you!
I don't want to die!
to you how
was someone from the 80s supposed to figure this out back in
the day people actually use guidebooks and like strategy
things Ike you I don't there were some games that you could
not beat unless you had an actual strategy book to use and
took notes yeah
Okay, maybe.
Oh, maybe.
But I'm not even, like, dying to my own...
Oh!
I take it back.
I am dying to my own thing.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, alright.
Go down, bug.
Oh!
It's a specific spot.
But before I wasn't even dying to my own bombs.
So I also have to specifically die.
I won't know what the spot is.
Unless I die on the spot.
Oh, that's the most frustrating part about it.
Okay.
Skill issue.
Just die better.
Why aren't you, why aren't you dying, idiot?
Do you have a game, genie?
No I never had a game, genie.
Oops.
Oh my god, that guy came from the water!
Nasty!
Oh,
I did it again.
I did this last time too.
To be fair, you're so bad at it, you came back twice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see your playthrough, Emmanuel.
Huh?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just finding the door.
So...
Oh!
Oh, tried falling down the hole in the bridge.
I think I'll just die.
I don't think I'll go anywhere.
Oh my god, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Wait.
There we go.
So maybe I do die here.
Okay, hold on.
Let's try every corner of this bridge.
Oh no.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Okay, this is a platform.
Oh wow, there's a lot of guys here.
Let's go up and up.
And up.
Pshoo!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Duck.
Actually, I'm gonna go up.
Oh, these guys stick to the ceiling!
Oh no, no, no.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was so close.
Oh, door!
Wait, but is this the door?
Ninety-thirds!
Uh-oh.
I think I have to blow myself up here.
No, I do not.
Oh my god.
I almost ruined it.
96th!
Mommy!
Die.
Oh no, mommy.
Mommy, mommy, real.
Mommy, real.
mommy oh mommy real mommy real mommy real mommy real mommy
real mommy I don't know what I just got but okay mommy mommy
mommy these
guys are so cute mommy sorry Mommy, sorry.
Mommy.
Oh, just...
Okay.
Just an enemy rush?
I guess so.
I should have...
My bad.
Oh, well.
Please.
I feel like I'm gonna run out of time.
Oh, we're almost out of the tunnel.
We're almost out of the tunnel!
We're almost out!
Okay, all right.
I probably didn't need to do that, but I was nervous, okay?
Don't risk it.
Don't- 98!
Don't risk it!
Okay, what is that?
Oh my gosh.
What is it, though?
Hmm.
Where do I go here?
Okay, here.
Nice.
Oh yeah.
Hmm?
Okay.
I'm not quite sure how this...
I see stuff over there, but I can't see anything.
Oh!
The momentum!
Hmm.
Oh god, this stage.
Is it like an invisible floor or something or...
No?
No, okay.
What do you mean a graphical error?
Don't overthink it!
Wait, so do I go to...
Which...
It's the treasure chest wraparound.
Oh, okay, okay.
You can just, you can jump.
Oh, there's not anything on the right side.
Oh, oh, shoot.
No way.
Am I trapped in here?
Ah, I don't know how to do.
I don't know.
Oh, my God, that was so close.
So close.
Heep.
Okay.
Slow and steady.
Don't fall, don't fall.
Nice.
Okay.
Um.
Oh.
Wait, hello?
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Uh, oh.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Shoot, shoot.
Oh, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure,
sure, okay, okay.
Nice.
Just one more, mommy.
I hope I'm going the right way.
Oh, no, they're coming from this way, too!
Okay, okay, run, run, run.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Please.
I would have been really, been really sad if I had died of
that butt.
Okay.
I can't tell if I can jump over these guys or not, but I'm
not gonna risk it.
It's a lot of mummies.
It's so many mummies!
Get out of here!
Oh no, no, no, no!
Oh my god, no, no, no, no!
Oh my god.
Go away, mummy!
I hope I don't even know if I'm going the right way.
I don't even know if I'm going the right way.
Okay.
All right.
Onwards.
Atlantis, no Nazo!
Atlantis, your Nazo will be solved by my hands and my brain.
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
I'm gonna run out of time.
Okay, I think I have to risk it.
I have to risk it.
Oh my god.
You know what?
It's fine.
I ran out of time anyway.
Is your rage meter still at 0%?
Yeah, actually I'm feeling not so bad.
Oh my god.
Poop bat!
Sometimes they're like glitching on the sides and it's
freaking me out.
Where's all the mummies at?
What the hell is this?
Where are the mummies at?
Yippee!
Oh, there they are.
That looks suspicious.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Wait, please!
Oh!
Wait, what's that door up there?
Oh.
Woo!
Okay.
Yikes.
Oh my god, the timing is...
Oh my god.
You have to be speed, Minto.
What if I just jump over it?
Oh!
I only have two lives left.
Can you duck and bomb?
We'll see.
Oh my god, if I bomb, I sit up so I get hit.
Oh my god, no way.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, he shoots both ways.
Is that even possible to do?
I don't even think that's possible.
How am I supposed to jump and duck at the same time?
It is?
It's possible?
Yes, but it's hard.
Oh my god.
Even the AI dies on level 10.
This room is insanely precise to do without a power-up.
Kodani did it, but it took many attempts to memorize.
Okay.
So now we have two options here.
Now we have two options here.
We can either.
Where's my strategy guide?
We can either go that route.
Which, now that I know how to get past 50 seconds, it's not
so bad.
It's not so bad getting past it and getting to the rest of
it.
It would be the hundredth that would be the most difficult.
But there's also this invincibility route, but that also
involves going through eight, which isn't, in theory, I
guess, so bad, but ten!
Ten is where we would really struggle, I think.
I say we.
It's really just me.
You'll get better at eight and ten.
You think so?
10 was the trees and the clouds?
Yeah, 10 was the trees and the clouds.
And then I don't even know what's beyond there.
But it's the invincibility route.
So I'm assuming the star makes us invincible.
Against enemies.
I'll make a pull.
Which route, which seat should I take?
Which route should we take?
Route 10.
Actually, I'll say, uh, route, invin-sib, uh, route 10.
Route 100.
I guess those are the most difficult ones.
Nagoya.
No!
Harem route.
Hi, wait.
I don't mind trying 10 a couple more times but like how long
of a route how long is it you know I'm scared why is it
50-50 what's wrong with you guys which path leads to
Akihabara I don't know
the route is a 10 but it's impossible Rout 100 is winning.
Are there two different level 100?
I don't know, actually.
I have no idea.
What is this level even?
There's so much of this game that I feel like...
Look, 88, we also get a star.
There's so much of this game that we're skipping over, but
you know what?
Oh, oh, my bad.
The dark zone.
Wait.
I'm trying to...
What is the dark zone?
Ah, stop it!
I'm trying to read.
Dark zone and freeze zone.
Interesting.
A zone that is dark.
55%...
56% on Route 100.
This is killing me.
I'm not even watching this screen.
But just hearing the game start and then he jumps and
immediately dies is kind of sending me All right, the
mystery adventure starts
I had to jump over that though.
I just got the timing wrong
Sunsoft started doing stuff again and I hope they come back
to this game
Wow what are you a masochist
though it's kind of interesting seeing that it's like not
like you can I can only play this in the JP side you know so
Okay.
Oops.
Wrong way.
Okay, let's get some points so we can...
I think you'll get more health.
Yeah, we're back to the seven, so awesome.
Oh, my game...
Glitched for a second.
And now we know where to go.
Okay.
So I'm not so scared.
Just a little scared.
Oh.
Uh.
Yippee!
I want...
I'm so curious what those chests are.
Oh, okay.
I remember this one.
Uh.
Ooh.
Oh, don't, don't, don't, don't poop on me.
I can't tell if I'm killing anything.
Hopa-bopopopopop.
Ah!
Oh, my god.
Oh my god.
I don't know how I live.
I don't know how I live through.
Okay.
Oh, sheesh.
Okay, and here we blow up.
Easy peasy.
What was this one again?
Oh, mummy.
Mommy time.
This one we just keep running.
Mommy.
Have you ever played La Mulana?
Oh my gosh.
I need to pay attention.
It sounds familiar.
But I've never played it before.
Maybe if I saw it, I'd know.
Oh, cute.
There was like another game that I'm Oh my god, wait, oh my
god, wait, oh wait, wait, wait Wait,
oh, wait, wait, wait Are you kidding me?
Since when could you throw fireballs?
Since when could you throw fireballs at me?
He just pulled out a gun.
Yo!
messed up he said call an ambulance but not for me can
you imagine if you couldn't move while like the bomb was
while the bomb was deployed to how much more difficult can
we make this game there's a second version of mummies with
ranged attacks and they look they look the exact same
There's no distinction between them.
Before, I think I just ran...
I think I just was able to run past him, so I didn't even
pay him any...
I think he was in a different spot before, so I didn't have
to pay him any mind.
Uh-oh.
I think the less creatures that are in the front, the more
that are in the tube.
Oh.
Okay, we didn't struggle before because the RNG was on our
side, but I have faith we can get through this as well, even
though we're wasting a little bit of lives.
I just have to get used to this new zombie fellow, you know,
our new mummy friend with his gun.
They only shoot fireballs if they hit a ledge.
They're like, I'm not attacking you enough.
I really gotta...
I really gotta get you good.
Are these supposed to be scorpions or...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Uh, there we go.
Earwigs.
Oh, gross.
I wonder if it's worth getting that.
Oh!
I didn't know there were some guys up here.
Slow and steady.
Why?
Sometimes he doesn't fall off the ledge.
Ow!
No, no, no, no, no.
I almost blew myself up.
Sometimes he doesn't walk off the ledge, and sometimes he's
just like...
Sometimes he's just like, yep.
I'm just gonna keep going.
what why you saw last time I was able to do it by just kind
of inching my way over what was the difference oh what was
the difference walk the other direction I think when you're
falling oh my gosh oh okay there we go 99th zone okay oh I I
can jump over these guys.
Just kidding.
How many lives do I have left?
Only five.
She's silly, I love her.
Thank you for the donut.
Do you guys think that making sound effects enhances your
gaming ability?
Because I believe it does.
for me, personally.
You know?
I believe it allows me to go further beyond.
Help!
Never mind.
Yeah, I'm going this way.
Don't poop on me.
Oh!
If I had just waited...
Oh, wait.
Oh, they started throwing stuff.
Did you see that?
It would have actually been impossible to get there
because...
Oh, not impossible.
We would have just had to kill them.
I don't know what to think about.
But also, we would have had to kill them while ducking the
whole time.
And I can't duck and shoot at the same time.
Why is my RNG so bad this time?
Okay.
I'm fine.
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Let's go this way.
Oh, I pressed the wrong button.
That was my fault.
I think I'm going to game over, yeah.
Seems you had really good RNG in this level previous.
It's true.
There was the second time that it went through and there was
no zombies.
Battle cries definitely help enhance gameplay.
It's okay.
I don't think I want to go through Zone 100.
You guys, I'm thinking about it.
I don't know if I want to go through Zone 100.
Let's try Zone 10 a little more.
I think I'm better with jumping now, right?
so I think I think I might be able to do it wait how do I go
through three and then I skip right is that what it was I
can't remember actually
we decided to go this way I go to three and then I go to yes
because I got to get the boots at six and this is fish watch
out for fish watch out for fish Watch out for fish, watch
out for fish, watch out for fish, watch out for fish, okay.
And it's this one.
This one right there.
Yippee!
Eighth zone!
Oh no, I forgot about the eighth zone.
Oh, oh eighth zone.
Eighth zone, please be kind to me.
is what has made me better at the game, truly.
Just mastering, I can't say that I've mastered it, but
getting past this zone is what I think made me better at the
game.
Okay.
There.
Oh my god.
I say as I die.
I hate zone 8.
I hate.
Zone 8, I hate Zone 8, I hate Zone 8, I hate Zone 8, I hate
Zone 8, I hate it!
Why are there two of you?
I hate Zone 8!
Oh, that was a close one.
Phew, shoo, shoo, shoo.
Oh, uh, my bad.
Did not mean to...
You know what?
That's fine.
And we're back here.
I remember my strats to, oh my gosh.
Shup, ah, shup.
Shup.
Okay, good, good, good, good.
Okay, now we, be careful here.
Shup, shup.
Okay.
We made it.
That's the most difficult part for me.
Shup.
Oh, I don't have a lot of time left, though.
We made it!
Okay.
And it was about here.
Yes.
I'm really having to like take such deep breaths with this
level.
Pixel.
Perfect.
Precision.
It's not... You can't just jump off.
atlantis man please you can't just jump off okay you can't
just jump off would you please
no why john atlantis
i wish there was a i was gonna say i wish there was a way
that i could just practice the stage over and over again and
I mean technically if I were to save state it I could but
I'm not going to do that I'm going to do it proper oh my god
why did I not just jump to the next one I knew the next one
would make it
okay and then if I don't get the star I have to go back
which is even worse I have to go back I have to go all the
way back And try and get it again Okay Oh nice I made it
somehow
The worst part is If I don't If I don't make it past it Or
if I make it past this And then And then there's an even
harder level.
What do I do?
Because it'll make the last level easy because I'll have
this invincibility.
But if there's something even worse than this,
it's these tiny guys, you know, in the middle.
Okay.
Just jump.
Ah!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh, yo, yo.
That was a close one.
Boop.
Okay.
Oh, my ear is just...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
One thing I think is the most forgiving about this game is,
like, with specifically these guys, you can, oh, you can
shoot the bomb anywhere on the screen and they'll, like,
duck, you know?
So if I, like, have to do it, like, in front of them or
beside them so that it doesn't hit me too, it all works out.
There we go.
Third zone.
Oh god, you have to screen start from zone one.
Oh, yeah.
What do you think this was?
Fish!
This one.
Sixth zone.
Oh, I missed the exit.
I missed the exit.
game eighth zone
eighth zone I said that about eighth zone but maybe maybe um
tenth zone will make me really good at this game too I guess
we'll have to see if I can ever clear it my god it seems
like the most impossible feat ever
Oh, okay, we're here.
Nice.
All right.
Oh,
you can't jump down from the third flap.
Oh.
Whoa, that was close.
This one works fine.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
You have to go from the tippy top.
Just in case I fell through there.
Oh my god.
I knew that was gonna happen.
As soon as it happened.
As soon as I touched the wall, I was like, I'm gonna, this
damn bomb's gonna explode in my face.
Oh.
Music.
What the?
Where did you come from?
There's never been a...
Oh, crap here!
Nice.
Okay.
Please.
That was close.
But close still means we made it.
For now.
Okay.
Yes.
Tenth zone.
Orangey is a cruel mistress.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I got the shoes, right?
Or am I...
Oh, okay, yeah.
I don't know why.
Everything's starting to blend together.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god, no!
Wait, am I an idiot?
Yes, yes you are mate.
You're stupid!
Oh my
god.
Okay.
You know what?
Grab that.
Maybe we'll get an extra life from it.
Oh my god, that was so close.
Hoi.
Hoi!
I think this is where I typically start.
No, no.
Hoi!
Did it!
And now I'm invincible!
I think!
Yeah, I'm invincible!
Unless he's a friend.
Oh my gosh, imagine if like a mimic ate me.
You can jump at me all you want, Bozo.
I can take it.
I can take a hint.
But I can't take a hint!
Oh my god.
Oh wait, ah!
Oh, I almost died to my bomb, I think.
Okay.
See ya.
see you suckers my game is lagging for some reason okay oh
is this a maze oh okay I'm just gonna keep going left ignore
ignore chest okay oh gosh it's a maze oh with time not on
our side oh it's a slug just keep going left oh darn it
again just keep going left just keep going left keep
Okay, okay.
Oh!
Sixteenth is out!
What are these?
Oh.
Ooh.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, being invincible is awesome!
Okay, I can't.
Ignore it, ignore it, ignore it, ignore it.
I wonder if this place has a hidden...
door or not.
That's my biggest worry is losing a life because I'm just
walking and walking and I'm walking in circles like what
appears to be happening now.
Oh, never mind.
Five!
Oh!
She can tank the poop!
Hell yeah, I can tank the poop.
I can tank it!
Oh, okay.
I'm all- I'm- I'm covered in shit.
I'm- I'm- I'm- that's why- that's why they're leaving me
alone because I'm so smelly right now.
Okay.
This game has gotten infinitely easier.
But where's the door?
Speak and you shall receive.
21st zone!
Wait.
Is this it?
Is this the one I'm supposed to go through?
23rd zone?
I don't remember how many there were.
Between.
I feel like I've...
I feel like I messed up.
Uh-oh.
Wait, what do I...
Where do I...
Oh, do I have to make that?
Okay.
Nice.
Just keep going, I guess.
Yippee!
But I think if I die, I'll lose the star.
Okay.
27th zone?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
what is this what is this evil what are you oh my god
should i be checking the strategy guide i have no idea i
mean i'm still invincible so i'll just keep going for now oh
my gosh please
Oh gosh.
Oh nice.
Wiki how?
I'm gonna pause real quick.
I'm actually...
What am I on?
20.
Uh oh.
I'm on the red path.
I was supposed to go to four.
Now where am I?
I'm on the 23rd.
I'm on the blue path.
Oh my god, no.
What happened?
Where did the blue...
Where did the four-door go?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
God, I'm gonna have to do tech...
Wait a second.
There's two choices here.
Which door?
Which door can I take?
29th zone.
Oh, sorry!
Sorry, sorry!
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
There was two doors.
Wait, actually now I want to see where I am again.
Which door would that have gone to?
Wait, what am I at?
I have no idea anymore.
You know what?
Whatever.
We're just...
This is it.
Can I...
Is this land?
Oh, okay.
It is land.
Look at these little skulls.
Oh, wowie!
Oh, are you kidding me right now?
Are you kidding me right now?
I have to make that?
Okay, I made it.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I'm so good.
What the?
I'm taking the last door.
31st zone.
Oh, I got a lot of points.
actually I wonder if it does make me it does want me to go
back probably because it probably wants me to go back
because there were like several doors so you know what let's
just go back 31st zone I probably have so many lives now but
if I think I fall I completely lose oh my god I completely
lose my invincibility why are you oh it's getting stuck on
these guys stop i'm trying to open the second door
42nd zone
get trolled i guess i
don't even know if i could be mad i don't even know if i
could be mad Oh, whoops.
I changed it, but I don't even know if I can be angry.
Are you mad, Mint?
I don't think so.
I think I'm really sad that I have to go through Zone 10
again.
I think I'm just more sad that I have to go through.
How do I find?
Okay, we're gonna have to find door floor.
Okay.
When we...
If I get past Zone...
If I can get past Zone 10, I have to find the...
Oh my god.
Damn it.
Was this game made by Millennium Game Development?
The rage refuses to manifest.
Yeah.
Actually, I think I kind of want to start over.
I think I want to start over with all seven lives.
I...
I want to start over with all seven lives.
Punished, Binto.
What's the goal in this game?
To discover the mystery of Atlantis.
Atlantis no Nazo.
Oh, I cannot believe that there was three doors.
And one of them was just a black hole that...
Stole all of my lives.
I mean, I can believe it.
I'm gonna skip over that so that I don't accidentally get an
extra life.
Okay, alright.
Atlantis truly is a mysterious place.
Why did they build a door that leads to your death?
Oh, oh my god, I'm playing.
Oh my god.
Okay, actually
Oh, that was close.
Okay, I wanted to grab that so we get a little extra bonus
score for when we want to get an extra life.
I don't remember how much you need for an extra life, but
every little bit helps, I think.
Oh, oh my god.
Wait, no, no, no, I am going through here.
I forgot.
Oh.
All the doors lead to your death, boss.
Where would it have gone if we hadn't gone through that one?
And I even opened the first one.
I'm such an idiot.
God.
And I got like a million points from the last door.
And of course I was so excited about getting through.
I mean, of course, who would have, you know, I think anybody
would have thought that that door led to...
to level 4, probably.
If they passed zone 10, I imagine.
Third zone!
Okay.
Feesh.
Wait, it's this one.
Sorry, I got a little confused.
Okay, okay, okay.
Please.
Eighth zone.
Alright, here's where we struggle.
That's okay though.
I am stronger.
I am not the same mint I was.
20.
Nay.
30.
An hour ago.
I have learned.
I have grown.
I have nazoed.
Oh my, okay, first of all, that didn't affect him.
Second of all, I'm very happy that I didn't die, but why did
that not affect him?
Why did he not go into his little shell?
Oh, wait.
Actually, I want him to go.
There we go.
Um, why?
He fears nothing.
Okay, here's this part.
We need you to go away.
Thank you.
And we need you to go away, thank you.
And we need you to go away.
Thank.
I really thought I had it.
Clutch bomb, but I really thought I had it.
I thought so.
I thought I had it.
Thank.
I do want to thank this game for testing my patience.
Giving me a new appreciation on Afterlife.
Thank you, game.
To whoever created this game, I hope you know that you
have...
There's a very special place in hell for you.
Oh my gosh, I'm so...
I'm so scared of this part!
Oh my gosh, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, all right.
Oh my gosh, am I gonna make it?
Do I have enough time?
Oh my God, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know.
Okay, oh my God.
Okay, we have six lives.
Not bad.
Okay.
In fact, I am gonna grab that.
Maybe get an extra life.
I don't know if it does or not.
No!
Ugh!
That's fine.
Oh god!
Ugh!
That's fine!
Jump King No Nazo.
There's a second door to the eighth stage, remember?
What about it?
Oh my god!
You can grab the star and go back.
Where did the...
Where did that stage lead to?
I actually don't remember.
No, that went to Nazo.
Nagoya, didn't it?
That went to Nagoya, didn't it?
Oh my god.
Oh yeah!
Hoi!
Huy!
Where's the secret door?
Where's the other door?
I can't go anywhere else!
No way!
No, no, no, no, no.
Pause the game.
Does this lead to four?
Okay, I'm going to check.
It is four that I need to go to.
Yes, ten to four.
Ten to four.
You're up soon.
Thanks, Amore!
She's grunting like that because she's actually jumping in
her room as she plays.
This goes to 12.
We don't have so much time, you guys.
Wait.
You might be wondering, what the heck are you doing, Minto?
I'm gonna go back.
Do I have to...
I'm scared.
Do I have to bomb myself?
in front of the door?
Or somewhere?
Do I have to die to a bomb somewhere?
Hmm.
I don't think it's...
No, no, no.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Okay, I have to go.
bomb here okay okay okay now with precision take it with
precision fourth zone where am I oh I'm up here okay well
the spikes kill me no okay
Jump!
Alright, now, hold on, sorry, I don't mean to pause again.
I'm looking for, I'm looking for door 25, 25.
I wish these were labeled.
25, 25, 25.
Hoi!
Seven!
Time to go back.
Leave me alone.
Okay.
Leave me alone!
Seven.
Okay, keep on searching.
Okay, it's gonna be around here somewhere.
Here!
Third!
Four.
Um...
Is there anything over there?
If I jump...
Oh...
Check to the right.
fourth zone can I make this actually I don't know I don't
think I can make this unless I oh no I have one wait this
might be okay wait no it's not okay this is not okay I have
one life left and no way to get down
there we go
I lost my invincibility.
I lost my...
Jax, thank you.
Are you an invincibility?
Well, well, I mean...
We're closer to...
Okay, one, two, three, six, eight, ten, four.
Um...
One, two, three, no, four, five, six, seven.
One, two, three, four, five.
On this route, we only have five more levels.
left so i think we're we're over halfway there and i can get
past level 10 now so i think that's that is a win in my book
quite honestly
it's only been it's only been four hours we're fine
I'm starting to get hungry though.
But I have some food that I can...
What?!
I threw the bomb!
You!
This is where I should not be losing lives at!
Okay, I'm gonna start over.
I'm gonna start over.
Just kill me.
Rage meter 0%
Is the rage meter broken?
No, I don't think so.
Beep, beep, beep.
No.
I think I'm at rage 5%.
Just because of that one snail.
Really grind my gears.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can reset the game from the Switch menu.
I'm trying to pretend I'm not on the Switch.
I'm trying to be like...
Look at me playing Famicom game.
So just pretend you don't see the Switch menu on the bottom,
okay?
Just pretend.
Oh.
Oh!
Minto gaming!
I'm gonna go get some food.
I'll be right back.
I'll be, I'll be like a second because I don't have to heat
it up.
It's just some like some cheese and crackers and stuff.
So I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
We're gonna have a short, we're gonna have a short
intermission.
The short, short intermission.
So I can, so I can eat.
So I'm gonna just turn this off so we don't have to listen
to it.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I got, oh my gosh.
I got some of my favorite cake last night.
So I am gonna eat some of that for you.
energy.
And I have some chicken salad and some crackers.
I mean, not crackers.
I thought they were crackers.
It's some bread.
And some cheese.
And some grapes.
Rage reducing cake.
It's my favorite cake ever.
It's so delicious.
But it's from a specific store.
So if I like ever move away, I'll never be able to get it
again, you know?
It might be one of the only things keeping me here.
Mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm,
mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm.
Maybe, actually, I'm gonna turn on some music, so I'm not
just...
Eating.
Oh, this is, this song is called Lemon Cake.
How, how fitting.
Oh my god, it's loud though.
Yummy.
Just a short little five-minute break for me to eat.
I could barely open this.
My hands are starting to shake because of the caffeine.
And also, it's hard to open things anyway when you're a
ghost.
Oh, boom.
you know I'm proud of how much progress I've made so far
especially with stage 10 I was really thinking it would be
impossible and I've done it twice now so all in all good
you've honestly made it pretty far into the game and like
it's been four hours but we've tried different route so
platforming pretty well yippee you're accidentally taking
wrong routes more exploration so that's nice yeah exactly do
you want to try another family com rage kusuge try
transformers convoy no nozzle i can't remember is cheetah
men a kusuge or is it just silly beep beep and those are
also um i I want to play Ernest Evans too.
It's horrible.
Oh,
the music's off.
There's just something.
Wait, Cheetah Man is unfinished?
Oh, yeah.
Uh-oh.
is on the other screen the one that's being occupied by the
game so okay I got it though
I recommend Bugs Bunny birthday blowout for NES oh
so bad he couldn't even finish it could continue the game
center CX greatest hits and play Quest of Key sometime yeah
I would like to I think you know and the journey to become a
better gamer you must start at the basics and honestly this
feels like a good starting base you know when something is
so unfair and so so um I guess unfair something is so unfair
and so precise it gets It makes you, it hones your skill as
a gamer.
Don't forget your skills as a gamer.
So Mario next?
I don't like Mario.
I'm tired.
Pretty sure I played, um...
I played original Mario.
before I graduated and um I was I think I did I use save
states if anybody remembers I think I did you did I played
it yeah I don't remember if I uh you're pretty good hand
gesture thank you thanks for one month but um oh
my god that chicken salad oh my god
the texture of it the texture of it did not hit oh oh i
thought i was gonna oh i thought i was gonna throw up for
real okay no more no more chicken salad i thought i was
gonna throw up for real just now oh my god eat the cheese
eat the cheese
Choo!
Here's some cool story while you listen.
I just finished Fallout 1, a very old CRPG game back in the
community.
It was a rough experience, so since I lost my progress
yesterday, I had to play my older save.
It frustrated me, though.
But it's fine.
Congrats on...
You finished it.
Congrats!
I have been watching, I think because of the Fallout show.
Because of the show I've seen a lot more videos about
Fallout And it'll be like Creepy as Fallout Bunker And some
of them are like Some of them have like intrigued me enough
To where I'm like now I'm really interested in playing I
don't know if I'll stream it though
Fallout 1 is fantastic.
Oh yeah, the vaults, that's what I meant.
That's what, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're just like, this vault was creepy because it was an
experiment to see how people reacted if this and this
happened.
And I'm like, whoa!
I would love to watch you play Fallout.
I know nothing about it.
Except only what I've heard from those videos.
you said you couldn't play single game without single player
game without chat though it's not that i can't it's just
more fun i find that i enjoy the game more when i when i um
when i play with the chat and you guys reacting and i was
having fun together that's why i feel with this I'm not
raging so much because I'm like silly game
nah I have some cheese left over maybe okay I'm gonna have
one bite of cake for motivation yay oh open the cake not a
kusage but I think you get a kick out of haunting ground
Daniela is a very amazing spooky maid like me Since you
asked about GameCube stuff too, PN03's Vanessa is also good.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, look at the haunting ground.
I think I've heard of that.
Oh my God.
Speaking of spooky maids, at Disney.
At Tokyo Disney.
I don't know if it's American Disney too, but for the
haunted house ride, they had Mickey Mouse ears that were...
I don't even actually know if they were just ears, but they
were...
The girls at the haunted mansion that run the ride, they're
dressed up as like ghost maids.
And they're just so cute and they have sold their headbands.
I don't know, I hope, I don't know if it was like, if they
sell it year round or if it was just a Halloween thing one
year, but I saw someone wearing one and it was so cute.
And I searched the park, but I couldn't find one.
But oh my gosh, it's really cute.
I search, I recommend, like look up the haunted house
Haunted Mansion maids at Tokyo Disney.
They're so cute!
They dress as the maids and butlers.
Oh, they do?
Might be the same then.
Okay.
I had one bite.
I'm having one other bite.
How?
Wait, I should go put this in the fridge.
I'm gonna go put this back in the fridge so it doesn't get
warm and melt.
Okay, I'll be right back.
Just a little bit.
Also, I'm gonna get more water, so.
I'll be right back one more time.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I'm back.
And I'm ready.
Range meter.
Decrease.
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
Calculating.
Calculating percent.
Four percent.
Three percent.
Two percent.
Alrighty.
Are we ready?
Now we know how to get to level 4 And from there we don't
know what we're doing But we will figure it out Because we
are super smart And we will get it right on the first first
try And we won't get it wrong And we also won't die Oh Okay
Yeah take that, take that.
that take the...
Is it weird to be having so much fun with this game?
And when it's supposed to be like a rage game?
Drop down, drop down.
There we go.
Better to be safe than sorry.
A little.
Maybe I have gone insane maybe i've got insane like fish
fish fish it's a fish it's a fish fish oh it's a fish
but you've got fall you guys i recently learned that there's
okay so i always knew that i couldn't burp It's this one,
right?
Yeah.
I always knew that I couldn't burp, but I recently learned
that there's a thing for it.
It's called like...
I don't remember what it's called actually.
But I can't burp.
I can only make a weird sound in my throat.
It's really weird.
Sorry.
I thought about it because it just happened where my throat
was like...
And I was like...
I learned that that's a thing.
I'm actually incapable of burping.
I've never burped once.
Maybe as a baby.
But I don't even know.
I try.
People will be like, just...
I don't even know how to do it.
They're like, try.
And I'm like, ah.
Ah.
Oh, my God.
I need to pay attention a little bit more.
Have you also ever tried screaming?
after you let all the air out of your body?
She's gonna pass out.
That was so unfair.
No!
I did everything!
Actually robbed.
Oh my goodness.
Nice.
Was it because...
Where did I...
I actually don't know where I took too long on, to be
honest.
Everything is starting to, like, blur together.
And it's just becoming muscle memory at this point.
Oh, I
hate level 8.
I think I hate this level more than I hate 10.
Honestly.
Okay, we made it here.
Please leave.
Okay.
Zone 10.
Duh.
All right, guys.
All right.
We can do this.
We can do this!
That's not what I wanted to do, but that works.
BGM that burns your brain.
There's like two soundtracks in this, two, two songs in this
game.
But we're getting better.
getting better.
No.
Oh.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah.
I hate level 10.
I do hate level 8 more than 10, though.
I'm so good though will I run out of time now who knows I
think I did that relatively quickly though okay I think I
did that really Okay, so going to the third one is like
ideal.
I wanted to see if I could do it for the second one.
I wanted to see.
Sure.
Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me right now?
Wow.
Oh.
Are you kidding me?
Please, Mr. John Atlantis.
Please, Mr. John Atlantis, just use your feet.
Grab it with your toes.
There we go.
Acquired.
Oh, that was close.
Okay.
Cloud.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh, I didn't think I was going to make that.
Eww.
Yippee!
Wrong.
Oh.
Actually.
Wait.
I have to go through here first.
Do I have- Oh, I only have one life.
Oh, you guys!
You guys!
Oh.
This is not good.
This is not looking very good for me.
Okay, fourth zone!
Fourth zone, we're- we're- Okay, go this way instead.
Okay, okay.
No, no, okay.
I can make it with this, okay.
It's okay.
I know the secret for stage 10 now.
I know, I know how to get through stage 10 now.
And he has video games are proof that people used to need to
jump more to get around in their daily life.
Yes, this is historically accurate.
historically accurate.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh, that was close.
Hey, get out of here.
Oh.
Alright, John Atlantis.
Claim your title as the one true Atlantis king.
Okay, this goes to three.
Three?
We go to Six.
Fish incoming!
We'll let this guy fall.
Wait.
Why is the fish from another direction?
I thought the fish was gonna be from another direction now.
I thought the fish was gonna be in another direction now!
Fish incoming!
Let him drop.
I'm gonna start throwing them the opposite direction.
I came up with that in my brain.
I was like, wait a second, why am I throwing it towards
them?
And then, like, risking myself getting blown up if they
stop, Oh!
Only four lives left.
Oh, this is so bad, you guys!
Please.
I need you.
Four lives left for level eight.
It's not good.
This is not looking good.
This is not looking good, you guys.
Once you get the star, it doesn't matter.
Anyway, it does matter if I can't jump either.
I tried throwing the bomb and, oh, okay.
Redo time.
It's time to redo.
It's time to redo, there's no way.
These are all practice runs.
Sometimes in life we regress a little bit.
Or in afterlife.
Okay.
That's okay.
That was only stage 8.
8 out of 99, baby.
No worries here.
8 out of 99.
Pooh.
Should do this game for GDQ.
I would love to participate in a GDQ one day.
But like...
Oh god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
But I'm...
Me speedrunning anything?
I don't see that happening.
Maybe I could organize a VTubers games thing.
Oh my god, go, go, go!
I'm regressing right now.
Fish incoming!
Wait for the fish.
Let this guy die.
Fish incoming!
This one, right?
Yes.
Games done not so quick.
Oh
my gosh.
Come on, jump.
Please!
I am pressing A!
I think just, uh...
You know.
Oh, this is a lag!
No, I'm just kidding.
Oh, please.
Okay.
Yeah!
I'll let this guy go.
Please, please, I need to speed.
Oh gosh, I thought I was going to land in there.
First try, baby!
Yeah!
I knew that was, I knew I, I knew, I knew at the moment that
I had gotten too far.
I knew it, I knew it.
Oh, I knew in the moment.
What the?
Do points matter?
I believe if you get enough points, you get an extra life.
So, it is good to have.
It's good to get them when you can.
Yes, indeed.
There we go.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, wait.
My bad.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alrighty, alrighty.
F you chest.
Okay.
All right.
Um, I think, uh, this is like the safest way to get down.
Ha!
Oh!
Okay, okay.
It's the safest, it's the actually safest way to get down.
No!
I didn't.
I didn't jump soon enough.
Sure.
I lost the star!
I have to redo everything.
Oh!
Oh yeah.
I'm gonna die here.
Maybe.
Actually, I don't.
Are you coming over here or what?
Keep pushing forward.
You know what?
Maybe I can try...
Oops.
Dang it.
Maybe I can try level four without infinity to see...
To see...
But we need infinity for the last level.
But we can see where the next...
Where the door is, you know what I mean?
Where the door is to the next part?
Maybe, if we're good.
So let's at least try.
I don't know where the... duck!
Duck!
Oh no!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Gaming.
It's right here!
Oh god.
This part.
Um, hello?
I don't think this is possible.
Oh my gosh, I made it.
Okay, okay.
So it's just a few over.
As long as I can make the jump.
Oh duck, duck, duck, duck, duck, duck!
Oh my god!
I jumped too late?
Oh, gosh.
I'm surprised I made that other part, though.
There we go.
Duck.
Not duck.
But...
Ooh!
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
Quack.
What is this area?
30th zone?
I don't know where I'm supposed to be at.
Wait, hold on.
Let's check if this is correct.
It's not correct.
Wait, and then I can't go back.
Okay, well now we know, because otherwise we wouldn't have
known, right?
Right.
Learning is half the battle.
We wouldn't have known otherwise.
Oh my gosh.
Leave me alone.
Oh, ha-minto!
Let's explore a little bit.
Have I been here before?
Oh my gosh.
Look at all this.
Look at all this Atlantis imagery.
Including very tall bust.
And grave.
Yeah, I'm glad all you fuckers died, man.
Atlantis no butthole more like it.
Don't be so rude.
Is that a fountain?
Oh, it might be, actually.
Spicy mint.
Sorry, I am a little spicy right now.
We're gonna run out of time!
That's okay, okay.
When we go over there.
Do not go through that door.
Because you won't be able to get out.
So, we discovered another thing.
We discovered another thing.
Rage meter update when.
I'm actually not raging at all.
I'm actually pretty okay.
I thought I would be raging way more But I'm actually
alright I think we Okay never mind
These damn Crows Vultures, whatever they are
Poop Poop, poop, poop What annoys me the most is we There's
no in-between to get more points, you know?
Between now and...
I'm getting to level 10.
So it's just...
Pure skill, baby.
Pure skill...
I mean...
We did level 8.
One try.
I don't think we will again.
And...
Oh, wrong way.
And level 10 in like three tries.
Actually, I don't remember, it might've been four.
Who cares?
Atlantis, no unko.
So true.
Unchi everywhere.
Fish incoming!
Let this guy die.
They were a little late there, buddy.
I almost was proven...
I almost looked like a liar.
And there's no good!
Oh, I was like, what is this one?
Oh my god.
We game through there?
We game through that?
Okay, here we go.
everybody I don't know why I deployed that but it's fine
just for safe measure how I lived I don't know but I lived
birch wait for you to go okay no no yeah wait yeah wait okay
wait
Hoi!
Ah!
No!
I didn't, that was just me not getting enough of a head
start.
How many lives do I have left?
It's five?
Actually, not sure.
Okay.
Oh yeah, okay.
Oh yeah!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, I didn't know if
I was gonna make that.
Please, I need you to make jump longer strides, sir.
I know your legs can handle it.
Any crab percent.
Any crab person.
Remember, happy day!
I've already wasted a few seconds, man!
I mean, I say seconds, it's a few numbers.
I don't even know how fast it's going.
I knew I was gonna run into that guy.
I knew it.
Safe.
I'm so glad you can throw things in the air.
I'm so glad you can throw bombs in the air.
Or else I would have been done so.
Done so.
There's two of them.
Please.
Tell me 200.
Oh my god, please.
Please, sir.
Please, please, please.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Okay.
Four lives in the 10th zone.
It might not be enough, but we shall see.
I'm so this game is making me so out of breath.
Good, good, good.
Don't jinx it though.
Let's go!
Any crab percentages?
Yes, crabby.
Alright, now I just need to not mess it up here.
Okay.
Nice suit!
Okay!
25th zone!
Let's go!
Okay.
Now we know it's not that door.
What does this do?
What does this give me?
I can't get it.
Don't go through that, though.
Don't go through that.
So much poop, I know, right?
Um, oh shoot.
Okay, I'm gonna have to start blowing stuff up, I suppose.
Hoping for the best.
But, oh.
Hmm.
Looks like a clock.
Does it slow down the time?
Because if so, I really need that right now.
I really
need...
I wonder if I should just...
Okay.
here maybe because this is where
no do I go up no hmm I think if I collect that clock I go
straight into that door ah
okay um if any hint givers want to give a hint right now.
The clock slows down the timer to actual seconds.
Oh, that's so nice!
I want it!
Ah!
Please!
Unless it's like I have to blow up myself somewhere.
I'm afraid to blow up myself right here.
Blow up the right chest.
No.
Nothing.
I think I just already did that spot but i don't think i did
here next to the chest okay let's go let's go back through
oh okay i thought that that that killed me for a second okay
oh my god i was just i was just like what the hell okay
yippee 41st Zone!
Oh!
Oh wait.
Uh, is this another blow it up?
Uh-huh.
Um, if I put it down, it's gonna open up that door.
Hmm.
Um.
Uh.
Try it.
to create green rave when maybe if i bounce oh dang it i was
gonna say if i bounce it how the hell maybe i there we go
there we go there we go
94 oh no it's brown rave oh god it's brown rave everybody
Okay, I thought this was the ice area and I was nervous for
a second because I thought that it would be slippery, but
it's not at all, actually.
Oh my goodness, it's brown rave!
Wait, where do I go from here?
Uh oh, wait a second.
Wait a second, wait a second, wait a second, did I go the
wrong way?
Oh, shoot.
Hold on.
No, there's nothing that way either.
Wait, huh?
Okay, hold on.
Maybe next to this chest.
Oh, uh...
Okay, I guess not.
Uh...
Oh my god, please.
Actually, someone just tell me the answer so that I can get
out of here.
This is because this is so awful!
Oh, wait!
I think... Wait.
I think I remember this one from the game.
center episode oh no you guys we might be here for a while
oh no no no i lost time oh shoot i didn't notice the time
the rightmost ledge yes i remember i remember now oh no no i
might lose the star no no no i thought only if i fell i lost
the star Oh my god.
Oh.
God.
And then we have to watch this terrible flashing.
Oh gosh.
Oh, why is it, why is there like a motion blur there?
Are you guys seeing that?
What the, what is going on?
what's going on there dang oh that's so frustrating okay I
know it's on that ledge I have to like jump down place the
bomb jump kind of like how I was doing it before I know how
to do it I know how to do it actually I'm curious though one
second after 94, 97 and then 100 you guys It's just two more
after 94.
It's just two more.
And 100 will be super easy because we'll have the
invincibility.
Like, we've got this.
We got this.
We're so close.
We're so close, actually.
Okay.
If I can make it there without losing any lives in a stupid
way, then we might be able to do it.
100 is the victory lap if it can get there.
Exactly!
Because we'll have the invincibility.
But we've made such good progress.
Proud of us.
Why is the timer gotta be so cruel, though?
The flow of time is so cruel.
It's a cruel mistress.
Trust in your instincts as a soldier.
As a gamer.
Yes, Master!
Master Palette!
Fish incoming!
Why are you a backwards fish?
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
Sheesh.
Let these guys fall off the edge.
Fish incoming!
Fish, fish and cover!
Okay, sixth zone.
Oh, I missed it.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, that was so close.
That was so close.
All right, here we go.
Gaming, I'm gaming.
Oh,
I'm not gonna make it.
Oh, I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it, you guys.
I'm not gonna make it.
I don't have I'm not gonna make it.
Oh!
I made it!
Yippee!
I made
it!
Yippee!
Oh my god!
Oh god!
Oh!
Okay, okay.
Fourth zone.
Just don't...
Don't mess it up, Minto.
I don't know why I waited for that guy to pass.
I was just being courteous to him, I guess, you know.
Okay.
I'm gonna try and get through the poop rave as quickly as I
I possibly can, you guys.
I wish I could grab this.
I really wish I could.
Oh my god.
Okay, poop rave.
Ikiimasu.
Shield your eyes, please.
Shield your eyes.
Oh, sorry.
Actually, I thought the poop rave was right now.
Not bad.
Okay.
Poop rave.
Everything jumping at once is really a lot.
It's a little overwhelming.
All right.
We were doing so well.
It's okay.
You saw how quickly we got here.
We got back here so quickly.
I just want to get out of this damn room.
It's so awful at my eyes.
Okay.
We got there quickly though.
Update the rage meter.
Poop.
Grave.
Percent.
The green was so much worse though.
It actually was.
You are right.
I was actually concerned.
I was like, oh my gosh.
I really hope that...
Because I had no idea it was a thing.
I really hope that, like, I didn't cause anyone harm.
Like, if they were epileptic or something.
Oh my god.
I was actually legitimately worried.
Back from watching Shin Godzilla.
Nam was right as good.
Have you still not watched?
Shut up, J.B.
Shut the hell up!
Shut up!
and we're still not one
are you winning minto we're really close I'll be honest
we're actually so close you guys we're actually so close we
were actually so close I just timed the bomb wrong I've
timed the bomb wrong I timed uh
I actually was really concerned.
I was like, maybe I shouldn't play this game today because
exactly the reaction I wanted does go to.
I was like, I wonder if I'm going to get legitimately mad
because I'm a little sensitive this week.
So I was just like, uh-oh.
What if I like actually, actually start to rage?
Like, it's not fun for people watching.
It's time to jump wrong.
That's what I said.
It's Ghost Week.
The time of the...
It's time of every month where a ghost is more rageful.
Okay.
Alright.
Altergeist week.
Fish is coming!
Oh my gosh.
The things that I have to do to keep myself sane.
Fish is coming!
Okay.
Sixth zone.
Oh.
Oh my god.
What the?
Um.
Um, what was that, a secret door that I unlocked?
Did you guys see that?
There was another door!
I wonder where that went to.
Oh my gosh, I thought...
I thought I was gonna run into them.
That's why I stopped moving.
Because I was like, okay, I guess I'll die here.
I guess it's time for to die!
Oh, oh, oh.
That was clutch.
I'm like gripping my controller so hard right now!
It's kind of insane.
Hoi!
Nice.
Nice, uh...
Oh, oh my gosh.
I wonder if I should start grabbing that chest if I have
extra time if it will be enough for me to, like, get, uh, oh
my god, an extra life.
I was gonna say something, but I'm not gonna jinx this
level.
I'm not gonna jinx it.
I'm just not gonna say anything.
I'm so glad I've gotten better at this level, but...
Oh, man.
I'm throwing, I'm throwing, I'm throwing.
No.
I don't even know how many lives I have left.
I don't even know.
Not that many.
Not as many as I had.
At the beginning of the stage.
Why did I do that?
One!
I'm not mad.
I'm mostly just sad.
Daijobu.
Two.
Forgive me while I'm worried about your voice, the shrill
screams you were making, are too adorable.
Why is me screaming adorable?
That was too close for comfort.
I'm gonna try and get the treasure down here.
I think I have enough time to get it.
There we go.
Okay.
I love the sound of people suffering.
Fish incoming!
Oh, I was early.
Fish!
Fish incoming!
Please.
Okay, there we go.
Eighth zone.
Let's go!
Wow, there's no guys over here today.
They're all crammed up there instead.
And in there.
Hiya!
Sorry I get so quiet at this level, I'm really
concentrating.
It's only 13!
Messed up.
Oh, I thought I died real quick.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I don't know why I'm getting the timing on this.
Or I'm not getting the timing on this, rather.
Like, I'm getting it.
I'm doing so poorly with the timing.
This game is really playing mine games on me.
It's really...
It's really playing mine!
on me!
Oh!
Why?
My
goodness.
Okay.
What are we at?
Five lives?
Four?
Oh, shucks.
Nice number.
Spooky number.
Four.
And the fourth zone.
Okay, all right.
I hope you guys are just as invested as I am.
Alright, this one has the clock that I can possibly get.
Ugh.
What was it?
I think I went from this side.
No.
Nice!
Okay, alright.
Alright.
Even though I know I'm invincible, the poop still psychs me
out a little bit.
Okay, what is that hitbox?
Oh, right now we're invincible, so...
Alright, poop rave time!
Okay.
Nine lives!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Um, you guys, I don't...
If I jump, nothing happens.
Okay, time for leap of faith!
Oh my god!
Look at me taking all these hits.
No way.
No way!
What's over here?
Oh, okay, nothing.
Um...
Congratulations!
Oh,
is that it?
Oh my god, I can't believe we did that last level!
First try, no way!
Congratulations!
Why is the timer still going?
Can I leave?
I can!
Wait, maybe there's another side.
Maybe there's the other side.
Why is the timer still going?
Congratulations!
No, there's no door over here.
Yeah, you can play the whole game again!
But backwards!
Is that it?
You have to go backwards.
Wait, am I just in another?
I'm literally just in another.
No way.
Wait, there's actually...
There's not even an ending screen.
Congratulations!
Thank you for the Hakusupa.
Got them.
Thank you.
Oh, I got 51 cores.
Thank you for the Hakusupa.
Cheese.
Hold on.
Um...
I want to be a little taller than them.
Yippee!
We beat Atlantis No Naiso!
Wait, if the timer runs out, do I get a game over, I wonder?
We beat Atlantis No Naiso in way less time than I expected
it to.
Holy cow!
Way less time than I expected to.
This didn't feel like an endurance at all.
I got gamered my way through it.
Hold on, I can, uh, one second.
Yippee!
Congratulations!
Two, thank you!
It was the grip.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
This music is driving me crazy.
But I'm curious what happens when the timer goes out.
Congratulations, everybody.
This, oh, this is it.
This is it.
Here it comes.
Five more, there's no one.
Wow.
Oh, oh, what are you?
Oh, oh, boop!
No way.
It takes me back to the screen.
It just tells me congratulations, cat.
No way.
No way!
Sorry, I'm trying to adjust myself.
Oh my god.
That is ridiculous.
Okay, get me out of here, please.
Did it waste a life?
I don't actually know.
Did I waste a life doing that?
How do I get out of here?
Yeah, I did.
Yeah, who is this guy?
Why are you here?
Why does it look like you're sitting on the toilet?
What is this guy?
The mystery of Atlantis?
Was it the diamond I got?
Can you exit the room?
We can.
Oh my goodness, he's the nozzle.
Nuzzle, nozzle.
Thank you for the gift, dead.
Thank you.
Okay.
Do I still have... Oh, I don't have invincibility anymore
because I...
Because I died on the winning screen.
Okay.
Let's just waste all of our lives.
Wait, there's a door here.
What's in that door?
Now nobody can say you aren't a gamer.
Thank you.
Uh-oh, he's gonna start shooting at me.
Yep.
Oh my god.
This is...
Why is this game so hard?
It's so obtuse, rather.
I'm trying to die, but I'm too good at this game.
Wait, I want to see where this door went to.
Oh my god.
30 seconds zone, and it's pink.
What's the S?
Oh, oops, my bad.
We're in like a graveyard.
I don't know what's.
That just did...
Skelies!
Oh my gosh, look at them jump.
They're so silly.
Why am I still playing this game?
What's wrong with me?
Wow!
Why am I still playing this game?
S equals spooky.
Wait, if I...
Can I go this way?
No, I can't.
Congratulations, you have completed a great game.
Improve the justice of our culture.
What are you talking about?
Oh, I didn't even notice him.
Mint better than Arino Kacho confirmed.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
How do I please?
I just want to go to the home screen, honestly.
I really just want to go to the home screen.
screen please.
So I feel okay.
I cannot believe I beat this game.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe I beat this game.
I always, I thought that it would be, that I would have,
like, it would take me like three streams to beat it.
But no, I beat it.
Don't ignore that part.
Ignore don't look at that.
Don't look at the game over.
Congratulations.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Uh, give me a second.
Um.
One second, one second.
Uh, I gotta make us.
I gotta put everything up.
Hold on.
One second, you guys.
One second.
I gotta get the chat already.
Hold on.
Oh.
Wait, no, no, no.
I'm ruining everything.
Pop out chat.
There we go.
Gotta get everything ready.
Here we go.
Oh no, you can still hear it.
Oh no!
Stop!
Wow.
One second, let me also...
My computer.
There we go.
Oh!
I thought I was gonna be with you guys all day.
I mean, I kind of was.
But wow.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
The game is over.
Oh my goodness.
My goodness.
Wow, virulent.
I remember watching Corona Viening this live and it is an
honor and a privilege to see you doing it as well.
Congratulations.
God gave her want to try the way she did it because you guys
said it was more difficult.
Kind of curious how much more difficult it is.
I mean once you get the invincibility it's just like walk in
the park but um and I think I probably would have been stuck
on the on the poop rave more if I hadn't remembered where
the door was.
Not actually no I don't think.
I
rave more if I if I hadn't known where the door was so that
leap of faith was clutch I can't believe I cannot believe
that I did that last level in one shot I cannot believe
without invincibility it takes forever yeah I can imagine
but I'm curious the Korone San did the actual gamer way the
actual god gamer way maybe i took the easy way but oh wow it
was still it was still a time it was still a time oh oh wow
he's so loud oh my goodness sorry goodness gracious
I guess the real Atlantis no Nazo was the VTuber we gaslit
along the way.
It was hard either way, Minto.
Corrin, thanks.
Wow, we.
Corrin had to memorize the precise jump pattern to get
through it.
I want to try it.
Like I said, I like challenges.
And this was quite a challenge.
Nagoya equals three numbers It's the number It's the order
of statues you need to bomb to get the door that warps to
the end So it is Nagoya, 7, 3, 8 I bet Or I'm assuming Was
there even a single mermaid in this game?
There was the fish people, yeah!
There were the fish people!
The fish people!
11 hours The Fist and Darns would.
I, okay.
I don't know.
I prefer older rage games to newer rage games.
Because I feel like, I mean, not to say that older games
don't make them obtuse.
On, like, like on purpose.
Like, they are.
And they're still.
You know.
Angel, thank you.
Still, thanks for the chill stream.
but I don't know games that are made to be rage games are
different yeah I think so too right have you played echo the
dolphin yet oh my god I played that when I was a kid and it
scarred me that game my sister had a a the Sega Genesis
actually sorry it was the Sega nomad because the Genesis one
is the console or the like the home version right and the
nomad is the handheld we had the nomad and um we had we had
the Jurassic Park game Sonic 1 and 2 uh the Lion King game
which maybe I should try the Lion King game that is oh
actually oh my gosh I I think I could still play I think
there's still a way to play it I never got to play the
Winnie
The castle.
Maybe.
That Lion King game is hard.
It's so hard.
Maybe I should play the Lion King game.
And the Winnie the Pooh baseball game.
And yeah.
But we had that.
Lion King.
Jurassic Park.
We had a box with the Tasmanian Devil game.
which, ugh, I don't, but the game was not in there, luckily.
And we had Echo the Dolphin.
I don't think there was anything else that we had.
But I played a lot of Sonic, and I played a lot of Lion
King.
Actually, I played my good share of Echo and Jurassic Park
2.
And Jaco sticks with the 10 gifted!
M and Minto stands for masochist.
Lank in Game Gear is some deep kusum.
Yeah, maybe we'll have to play some more games like that.
The true...
Challenge games.
Sorry, my brain is melted right now.
My brain is so jelly right now.
Oh my gosh.
I feel like all the adrenaline just kind of crashed and now
I'm I did it Yippee!
Oh my gosh, Brick!
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Gratzen 200k, by the way.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Aladdin wasn't that cool, so I never played Aladdin yet.
I can make you a list.
If you want to post it in my general tag or my live tag.
Feel free.
But, uh, yeah.
I really thought I would be here all day.
Taki is all thanks for the dead gifted.
Those grippers can rest easy.
My hands are like, I'm like, I'm like opening and closing
them.
Like, okay.
All right, let's stretch.
Stretch them out.
Oh, wow.
Wait a second.
Uh-oh.
Um.
I'm okay.
Everything's good.
It's just texting.
Checking a text.
I'm meeting my...
I'm seeing my mom tomorrow.
But, um...
Uh...
I will be doing a Patreon...
Um...
Game tomorrow.
Uh...
You don't have to leave just yet.
Minecraft?
I'm still trying to find time to organize a collab so I can
get a tour of the V-Shojo Minecraft server, but I'm still
really scared of joining it.
It looks so intense with how many mods they have.
Tell your mom we said hi.
I will.
No.
Tomorrow is Mother's Day.
For I think a lot of people.
So...
Wildest duck, thanks for the Tony gifted!
Thank you!
You learned base Minecraft from nothing, you'll learn mods
too?
Okay.
I'm also nervous because there's like a lot of people on the
server that I don't know.
So I'm like, shy.
But...
Um...
Yeah.
I've seen their server mods, it's so cool.
I have to, I've seen a little bit of it, but I think it's
mostly like the crazy, I'm, I already, I already feel like I
don't utilize the crafting to its potential in regular
Minecraft, so I'm like, oh gosh, when it's modded, I'm going
to be like, a dirt house.
Dirt house.
Scary time.
Thank you!
Thanks for one month!
But yeah, um, next week, um, will be a bit of a shorter
week, actually.
Um, but I have a collab with my beloved Ayami Sensei!
Ah, let me check the date.
I believe it's on Tuesday.
I will be streaming on Monday because it is a short week.
Um, I'll be streaming Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, and then
I'll be off for a couple days.
following monday but uh i have on tuesday collab with ayami
sensei so yeah yeah i'm so excited yeah if you don't know
ayami sensei definitely go check out her twitter oh wait i
can i can get that i can link that to you oh okay i am me i
am me she does oh be careful it's a little um It's a
little...
Maybe sexy.
But she was, um...
She's Meru-san's mama from Hollow Live.
So...
Yeah, and her art is so sexy and cute.
What's the collab?
You'll just have to see.
It's actually, uh, not really a game, so...
was mad when my fallout one got corrupted.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I know, that would really frustrate me, too.
My birthday's on Monday.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Toy-Roxy!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Toy-Roxy.
But I'll be streaming on your birthday.
On Monday.
Monday, Monday, Monday.
Yeah, so I'm sorry that next week will be a little bit, a
little bit shorter.
But yeah.
Cool.
I think I'm gonna head out then.
I think I'm gonna, I think I'm just gonna go.
I'm like,
yeah yeah
I think I'm gonna head out rest my brain I think I'm gonna
go rest my brain I play balloons I think I'm gonna go play
balloons yeah thank you guys for cheering me on I wouldn't
have been able to complete it without your help for sure so
really appreciate you guys encouraging me and also um
calling me out when i'm bad and also uh helping me with some
of the puzzles thank you guys little word welcome back thank
you so yeah um see you if i see you guys tomorrow for the
patreon games and i'll see you tomorrow But if not, I'll see
you Monday.
And, um, yeah.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, guys.
Congratulations!
Bye-bye!
See you!